hello everybody welcome back to the i'm not
gm speed chess championship grand master
robert s alongside me today once again
grandmaster mont hamilton amman we have
a great matchup in store today don't we yeah
what's up robert what's up everybody we are
about to get into an exciting match up which is
going to be uh international master levi rosman
against national master james canty and i'm
very excited to call this one with you robert
me too these are two very popular chess content
creators and before we get into the specifics of
those two let's talk about the format overall
just to remind everybody what they are tuning
in for because it's a knockout tournament there
will be 75 minutes of the longest time patrol
a five minute plus one second increment blitz 45
minutes of three minute plus one second blitz and
then finally the 25 minutes of bullet chess and
there are those breaks in between we saw those
last time they can come in handy for players to
stop the bleeding if they've lost a couple of
games in a row and also just to refresh and
for our viewers to take a step back and enjoy
the chess but i'm on the prize fund as we see
here still the same as it in the round of 16.
we have a 500 per match pretty good prize
money for a couple hours of blitz right
yeah not bad at all i think it's it's nice that
basically if you are participating in the i am
not a gm tournament you are getting paid something
no matter what and it only gets better from there
for sure and it's by win percentage uh half of
that prize fund so there's always something to
play for even to the very last game no matter
what the score of the match is and speaking of
score matches let's take a peek at the overall
bracket last time we were together amman we saw
lawrence trent take down danny wrench and this
time we have the lower left side of the bracket
the four seed levee rosman that's gotham chess
taking on james cannon the third so it's an
international master vs national master matchup
down there in the bottom left so why don't we
start making predictions what are your thoughts
on about this match that we're going to see today
well a few things have to be said going into
this match robert um we can't forget that levy
is definitely the favorite going in but he might
not be as much of a favorite as as people think
so james canty i think one of the most uh kind
of remarkable things that i didn't really know
about him is that uh we checked his his bullet
rating and i think he was actually higher than
some of the international masters we commentated
the last match up lawrence trent danny wrench
like this guy's no joke and bullet he's actually
rocking like a a mid 2600 bullet rating which is
extremely impressive so uh james candy in the
bullet section you know beware beware i'm with
you because i think that's the time control where
you often see the stronger player or the player
who's just much more accustomed to playing online
they thrive in that quickest time patrol but james
candy iii no slouch in the bullet portion and he's
ready to take on levy and levy was in a slump we
saw him tweet about that saying he's finally out
of it he took down a grand master in a bunch of
blitz games he's feeling much more confident and
he's breathing a sigh of relief that that bad form
hopefully for him is a thing of the past but aman
i mean it is interesting because levy has to be
the favorite right he is much higher rated he has
the higher title but how do you kind of put that
aside when you're playing a head-to-head match
for so long because let's say james wins the first
game now sudden are you really still the favorite
the answer is yes objectively right statistically
speaking but how do you kind of quell the nerves
in a match like this well yeah you just always
refer to the betting lines robert always tell
yourself in the head i'm still a betting favorite
if you're if you're levy that that'll that'll
calm you right down um but no the the thing
is if you get behind in a match like this you
really have to have those cool nerves i think
that um being a streamer uh sometimes it means you
have more turbulent emotions but i think it can
also help keep those emotions in check uh because
you're streaming for a large audience some things
might not go your way while you're streaming you
have to maintain that entertainer phase and and
keep it cool so i think he probably has a lot of
experience in that department so could actually
help him uh in this match today absolutely and
well it's a natural segue when you're talking
about streaming for hours and trying to keep
your composure arena king season six did start
on monday we have another event this coming friday
here and it's always a lot of fun couple hours of
blitz chess there's going to be some chess 960 in
addition to classical well standard chess dishes
that's not classical time patrol but arena king
season six is already underway and among we have a
pretty huge announcement that was made just
the other day and that is that pog champs
three is happening as we see two of the biggest
streamers on the planet xqc and ludwig return
for season three of pogchamps and of course we
have an online chess first as code miko joins
the field as the first in vtuber tournament hosted
by chess.com so ahmand you see that graphic there
you're pretty pumped for another pog champs i
i like watching uh these kind of events where
you've got the you know the lower rated uh players
getting into chess being coached by the you know
the the studs of our chess community here and and
bringing a lot more eyes to the chess directory
robert so good thing all around i'm glad chats.com
brought it back absolutely it's going to be
another fun edition of pogchamps some new faces
we'll join the fold and it should be another great
event highly entertaining and i just love the
graphics on this by the way and i know that uh
yeah there's a lot of hard work put into it
but i just find it really cool with kind of
the backdrop behind the players and of course the
ludwig salute yep shout out to the graphic team
oh well we do have just a couple minutes now
before the match gets started if you're on the go
do download the app so you can watch all the games
they happen before your eyes you will not want to
miss this one as well two of our favorite content
creators james candy the third that's gm canty and
i think we need to have a word with him on because
that is explicitly not allowed in this tournament
gm canty there are no gm's in this field so to
revoke his invitation uh listen i i didn't realize
that the gm's could sneak in like that and with
the prizes that are at stake here robert i might
have to go for a username change one of these
days so you're gonna go on by amman i i am amman
i'm trying to figure out how i can do this just
change the a in your first name to iman right yeah
i might just add it on to k and v b i n k so we'll
show up as i am gm k mvp i think that works well
uh well we see the the players seated
levy as usual in a hoodie and i love
james's hat like the fact that it just says
that's not a move and nobody has that kind
of quick banter talk like james canty when it
comes to talking about chess it's just so fun
yeah you've never heard that expression it's it's
very much a chess-ism uh where you know you're
just playing a quick blitz game some guy does
something that looks pretty sketchy you're pretty
sure it's not a good move and immediately you look
at it you're like that's not a move you're talking
about buddies so yeah very much uh very much a gm
candy hat right there so i agree i like the i like
the swag for sure and well i see many people in
the chat talking about uh levy and you know who
they're putting their money on and well let's talk
about how big of a favor we think that levy is in
this match because he is the higher the rate of
two by quite a margin in bullet we talked about
how canty is a strong bullet player but levy's
bullet rating is something in the 2800s so that's
quite a force yeah yeah it's it's a lot higher
than um than candy's rating in most categories but
i think in bullet the the difference in the
rating is probably a bit less significant it's
really hard to judge but um i think that uh canty
definitely has his chances when you're 2600 plus
in in bullet you can take down 28 hundreds like
that's not out of your ballpark so definitely look
for the bullet section in this match to be quite
important and if the match is anywhere around
even or maybe a few games lead in either direction
going into the bullet then i think that could be
a deciding factor but levy's going to look to get
out to just a clean good start we already talked
about hey what happens if maybe he doesn't have
the best start how's he going to recover i think
the simplest answer is you know just don't lose
right just get off to a good start you don't have
to worry about that so he's probably looking to
get out of the gate with a comfortable lead and
and never look back yeah for sure and levy has
some huge victories under his belt in title
tuesday's past i remember he beat peter svidler at
some point so it's clear that he can punch up and
it is difficult i would say psychologically when
you feel that pressure that burden of being the
stronger player the higher rate of player because
then you start putting pressure on yourself to win
and you can't be like that in the game of chess
you need to be as objective as possible because
if you start thinking in results results-oriented
terms you're not really putting out your best
game so i think that levy just needs to go in
this with a very clear slate just say i'm playing
a strong player let's do this and if he does put
out his best chest he should be the favorite for
sure yeah and and let's not understate like being
the favorite going into a match that means james
can't i mean he's got nothing to lose no one is
sitting there you know expecting him to uh to
come in and crush levy that's not the expectation
so he's got nothing to lose he's coming in here
with with a head of steam and for myself robert
i don't really like being a heavy favorite when i
come into a match i don't know it kind of psyches
me out i'd i'd rather be on like equal playing
field or even be the underdog um so so levi's
gotta gotta deal with that uh however however he
does yeah absolutely especially as you know these
players know so many people are watching they're
used to it as you pointed out in mon because they
are big streamers at this point especially levy
gotham chess channels are just soaring these days
but then with all the eyeballs comes expectation
comes pressure and that could play a part but
he does look pretty chill right now he's just
waiting for the games to begin and while candy as
always he's just hanging in there he's just vibing
speaking of games beginning you you call it
robert and off we go off we and we don't have a
london system so for a second i thought we'd get
a london from levy with an early bishop f4 but
instead we're getting a king's indian so fighting
chess is definitely on the table here in game one
yeah um the the london is something that basically
levy a guy like levy or anyone that competes in
these type of events it's always going to have
in reserve it's like hey if things start going
poorly i always have this you know trusty opening
that i can rely on uh for a decent position but
let me try some more classical approaches here we
see just a normal d4 game into a king's indian and
already this uh somewhat crazy looking g4 move
robert can you explain this one to people who
might think that levy's gone mad and starting
to go king hunting early on well this move g4
is preemptive it's trying to anticipate black
moving the knight away and playing pawn to f5 but
it also has the benefit of playing h4 g5 h5 and
storming your pawns down the board and creating
attack of your own but i think the major issue as
a standard uh is when there's a king in the center
that king often is more vulnerable than a king
sitting on g8 with a fiance structure around it so
i mean amman this bishop f3 move also caught
me a bit off guard i thought they usually
put the pawn on f3 but it seems like levy's
going marching forward here for the attack
yeah it also seems like he kind of has a plan
or setup in mind that he's trying to go for
it i guess i wouldn't be surprised now that the
bishop's on f3 if this knight maybe found itself
going to g3 the nice thing about not playing the
pawn to f3 and first moving the pawn is that black
doesn't ever have access to the h5 square so
sometimes when the pawn is on f3 you plant that
knight on h5 and sometimes you even come into f4
white never wants to give away the bishop for the
knight like that and the way that he's done it
there's no knight h5 so that knight is going to
have to probably go backwards robert and then
we might see your plan h4h5 opening up that h5
and the fact that james is thinking i was about to
say i think he might be considering knight h5 even
though it's a pawn sacrifice if the queen ends
up on h5 the d3 square becomes available to that
knight on c5 so you can't just go ahead and grab
a pawn even if it looks free you have to think
of the consequences a few moves down the line so
levy first takes the knight on c5 now i think he
takes the other knight so we get a situation amman
two bishops but the two knights have an extra pawn
and those bishops don't exactly have open space
i feel like white has to objectively be better
but it could be difficult if suddenly james opens
the position up with the timely b5 or something
like that yeah i'm i'm waiting for f5 to appear on
the board in this position basically if you know
if the g pawn takes maybe the queen takes and
all of a sudden we have that immediate activity
and there's there's that f5 on the board it
is that typical looking move that you want to
play when you have those bishops bishops thrive in
open positions and as robert mentioned moves like
b5 moves like f5 they challenge the pawn chain
and even at the cost of potentially another pawn
just opening the position up i mean levy's king is
uh you know it doesn't have a lot of defenders uh
very close to him so this this
could actually work out for
for james but it's gonna be an exciting game
either way with two bishops against two knights
yeah it seems like white should have the
quicker attack because you stole a pawn that
was in front of black's king but if you cast a
queen side for white then queen a5 happens and
even if there's nothing concretely there it
just feels like a position where very quickly
black is picking up steam and often that's what
you need in a blitz game just to concern your
opponent even if there's nothing specifically that
is so dangerous it's like that threat is stronger
than the execution the very popular chess quote
so i think that holds true in a position like this
definitely and he's going for f3 so
so just looking to maintain the center
yeah and i saw the eval bar take a huge dip
there so there's something about that move that
is there's a drawback to it and i'm wondering
if just opening up the file to begin with
makes sense because uh that makes
your rook on a fade more powerful
perhaps you can play on both sides of the board
with that later coming to f2 for instance it just
feels like a situation where white needs to tread
carefully yeah in terms of concrete lines i was
even looking at takes takes rook f4 intending
bishop g4 and it kind of looks like maybe just
for a brief moment you could stop levy's king from
getting to the queen side which is exactly i was
going to say where he's going to go right now
yeah so levy quickly runs that king over and now
queen b4 comes to mind can i just pick off your
c4 pawn with my queen because and that's what's
played white doesn't have many defenders over
by his king so is black going to have the attack
here is white somehow going to press forward i
think they both are going to have the attack here
it's just one of these annoying positions where if
white ever plays g6 you play h6 and it's like wait
i should have something of a pawn on g6 your king
is there but that pawn on h6 just closes down the
entire king side absolutely yeah g6 h6 and there's
no g file for you to play on um it's not that easy
to break through whereas for black i don't know
what the evaluation of this might be but at least
you kind of know what you're up to you know you've
got b5 conan you're already hitting this pawn
knight e2 by levy this is sort of what i
expected he needs to finish his development
and we might see ideas like king b1 is a common
move knight g3 trying to get into g5 but b5 b4
by black is coming sooner than you'd like to see
it what about rook hg-1 rook g3 rook hd do i have
time for that probably not but i just don't see
how i attack and it's a position where it feels
like white has to go and attack the black king
but that feels very slow and black can always
move the f pawn because if that pawn goes you no
longer have access to the h3 square as the bishop
cuts down the diagonal yeah you in fact you
could even be worse you could wait for the guy
to go rook g3 and then play f4 and just cover the
square from there yeah i really feel like from a
psychological point of view it's easier to play as
black here i mean even a move like pawn takes c6
has the drawback of after b takes c6 the b file
opens up so you ruin black's pawn structure but
that opening of another file where your king is
that seems very dangerous yep um i think there's
probably a way to play where you maybe just take
on c6 and just double the rooks on the d file and
and sort of just just play chess from there um
you know you're covering b2 that way the knight's
always watching a2 and don't see a way that this
bishop on g7 can enter the game like if that pawn
on e5 almost disappears like if it wasn't there
or if it ever moves in this game white has to be
very very careful a queen h4 plate and that eval
bar takes another hit i think the previous move
white was apparently doing well according to the
engine but you and i robert we're looking at this
position and kind of reminding people that hey
it might look like an advantage for white but um
you know black's attacking ideas seem to be easier
to execute uh than whites and i think that's what
maybe levy's is kind of realizing here is the time
advantage is also quite significant yeah even in
this position uh it's actually difficult for black
as well because i'm looking at this position i'm
thinking pawn takes e4 i'm thinking of pawn takes
d5 i think do i leave the tension as it currently
exists i think i would take on d5 because i have
the bishops i want to open up the board but i
can see the drawback of that he does take on d5
because if the uh d file can be under white's
control that could be a problem for black but
i starting to like james position more and more
yeah and not that this was ever his intention
but with the queen on on h4 he can't take with
the e pawn there was a pin there and after
queen a6 i think his intention was to meet
this move with b3 and knight takes d5 but
maybe he's noticing after queen a6 like
taking that pawn is is actually not so not so
good he gets a 97 check maybe king h8 g6 but
that move h6 kind of always saves the day yeah the
knight and e2 is also hanging out maybe taking a2
is better honestly because uh you're closer to
the white king but then e2 is hanging in that
variation if the knight moves from c3 so maybe
there's some kind of knight d5 97 knight g6 check
like just a back and forth of a repetition if
the king goes to h8 but maybe that king goes to
f7 and now i think so and look at that bar takes
it takes dip again h6 has to be the response right
yeah i think he's he's trying to be tricky
because sometimes when you're intending these long
calculations and then you see like some line where
oh my pawn would be better if it was on g6 you
start with that move and then your opponent might
not expect that you're just sort of slowly subtly
inserting that into a long calculation right
and yeah that's a good point because for example
h takes g6 now oh it does it i was thinking
knight takes d5 becomes more powerful in many
of these variations because you no longer have
access to the h file so 97 could be devastating
but the problem with knight d5 is we're talking
about the a2 pawn the knight on e2 both hanging
rook g1 doesn't actually threaten anything just
yet the pawn on g6 is defended by the queen
but of course we see the potential here of
a knight coming to d5 or taking on g6 the
97 check there are many ideas for levy as we
like to say in chess it threatens to threaten
precisely that one of the scariest things um and
if d4 which as as you pointed out earlier kind of
wins quote unquote wins that night i think that's
what levy's actually intending to give up that
night play rook takes g6 get that other rook over
suddenly he's the one on the offensive so if canty
gets too greedy here he could flip completely in
levy's favor so don't be too worried if you're a
levy fan looking at that eval minus 2.5 although
this game's over not at all this game could just
go topsy turvy when everyone's attacking and we're
getting a bullet scramble because the players are
now down under 30 seconds per side the g6 pawn
feels weak black is up two pawns i would consider
playing he plays d4 i was considering pawn takes
e4 f takes and just trying to open the position up
for that rook on a fade but he goes this way i i
don't like this i feel like levy's levy's getting
what he wants that's the point of rook there with
time ticking down this is not it no no no this
can't be i mean you see the evaluation bar go up
very high in white sphere rook takes g6 threatens
rook g1 or even rook takes g7 sacrifices for a
quick mate this has to be winning for white oh
okay so he wants to slide the rook over first
which i just don't think it can be the right
way to go but i i see what he's trying to do and
he takes on g6 how do you do this queen f1 check
is just met by king b2 for example the king runs
away so how do you actually get out of this but
the thing is what's the actual threat because
rick takes g7 there's no rook g2 to follow up
oh that's a good point so like that's why
the rook was better on d1 which is why
canty's actually hooped himself by
checking that was the wrong thing to do
2.6 seconds levy's gonna get that win but
i think rook d2 was actually the mistake
and then canty said hang on let me fix that rook
for you and didn't realize he was doing that
and levy's attack pays off in game one robert
won nothing for levy yeah we should pull up an
analysis board real quick because that's a very
instructive moment that you're pointing out that
the rook needed access to the g file to make it
work so uh come on if you pull up the last game
yeah and just yeah that was just so instructive
there and that's why rook d2 was actually a bad
move and rough takes g6 was so strong yeah if
you start with rook takes g6 then basically
the threat is you're gonna take this you're
gonna bring the rook over give another check
so if i just make a move for black we'll show what
white is threatening something like this check and
leading to checkmate on e7 so you need to have
the g file accessible and in the game what we
actually saw was rook d2 and then rook g6 and now
that's not a threat because g2 is covered yep so
it's it's a slower approach and that's all the
time black would have needed to try to save the
king it was very difficult you're under duress on
the clock on the board james actually didn't even
seem like he realized he was in time trouble and
that can be something that players fall victim to
in these five-minute portions because they're not
used to having so much time and they think that
they have all the time in the world and next thing
you know your clock has fallen absolutely and and
both of these players in that time scramble didn't
look the most comfortable but i'll give credit to
levy there because he was like 20 seconds to
about a minute minute and a half or something
and he was really down on time and he clawed all
the way back in order to get that win on time so
very impressive speed and and accuracy at the same
time uh by levy for sure and has levy been taking
lessons from yasser sarwan because he's playing
the black side of a karo khan and it was the
panel variation which is why white is currently up
upon but they're doubled on the d file there and a
typical idea for black is to go knight c7 try to
win the pawn back but you have to consider things
like hey does bishop c4 just just played does
that save the pawn i mean you're talking about
lessons from yasser i was like wait a minute he's
down upon yes he would never touch this position
you know i've actually played yasser from
the white side of this position so you know
he doesn't mind sacrificing a pawn if it gives
him all this quick play and it's in his beloved
karakan where they're all pawns no hope yep that
makes a lot of sense and like queen takes a2
is the move that's sort of being indicated uh yeah
and queen a2 is played keeping a watch on that
pawn i wouldn't be surprised if like b5 was maybe
a move here i'm not too familiar with the theory
in this position robert but tons of pressure here
uh and b5 played yeah and i think the problem here
is the knight takes b5 actually drops a piece
for white because there's queen a5 check at the
end of the line so b5 is tactically sound yep and
i guess you could take on b5 with the bishop but
uh we basically looking at that position after
like bishop a6 white is not going to have any
hopes to castle and you know the price of a pawn
is pretty much not worth it definitely not and
this is what happens sometimes when you sort of
you win a pawn you try to protect it and you're
a little bit too focused on the material and it
makes sense because in many of these keracon lines
from the white side and the pan off you do try to
protect that pawn but here you're seeing uh how
james had to allow levy's pawns forward but the
downside of these pawn pushes right of mine is
that his pawn md5 could become a weakness as the
game continues yeah uh out of the opening i think
levy's got to be super happy with how it's gone
but um i'll just give credit to canty although
he may have ran into someone else's prep he might
not have the best opening he's kept the time even
in fact he's ahead on the clock and sometimes when
you get in these bad opening positions at least i
can speak for myself here robert i overthink them
you start to to worry that your opponent has just
got the whole game prepped and you get low on time
plus the bad position so whenever you're in a top
position play quick and at least give yourself a
chance on the clock yeah low on time is something
i'm very accustomed to so i feel that you're right
that oftentimes in blitz the best thing you can do
is play decent or good moves quickly rather than
trying to find the perfect move every single time
and look at james he's built up a large lead on
the clock still plenty of time of course for levy
his knight on d5 looks very strong but upon c3
is a target but that's what i was saying you'd
rather for black have your pawns on a7 and b6
in this position instead of on b5 where it's
very vulnerable and if b5 is captured then a4 is
a target next and i think black has sort of lost a
bit of uh the the pull in the last couple moves
like after pawn takes here i would be a little
bit more attracted to maybe the move bishop e6 and
leaving that knight on c7 guarding the pawn i feel
like after knight d5 bishop d2 uh you pointed out
earlier that that pawn might be a liability and
i'm just wondering you know like very very quickly
the pieces can all shift over to the b file you've
got the easy e-file access here and i'm not so
sure how easy it is to defend that pawn like
bishop a6 and bishop d7 both don't look like moves
that either are playable or that you want to play
totally with you and if especially in view
bishop d7 i guess it's not possible because
the knight d5 is hanging right now but that's
makes matters even worse so maybe bishop e6
tactically protecting b5 because of some
discoveries but then you're inviting the
queen over to b2 where you put another attacker
on b5 right it feels like an awkward position
yeah i think i think the queen is going to
slide to b2 and then we might see rook b8
something like that but i don't think you can
complain too much if you're candy here something
like rookie one maybe knight to g5 or trying to
get the knight to e5 eventually um there is this
weak c pawn to target but it almost feels like
levy doesn't quite have time to to fully exert
all the pressure on the c file because he's got
his own pawn to worry about absolutely and in
addition to going after a backwards pawn which
the pawn see there is you might want to blockade
it by putting a piece in c4 but you just don't
have time to get your knight to b6 and it's what
well seems a little unnecessary i guess it's the
best word um that i can use to describe it c4
right because of knight b6 then d5 yeah absolutely
knight there d5 um seems like you're handling
handling things he's gone for it there's the
rogues lose this bishop is is loose there's a lot
of things going on here but what you said earlier
ahmad look at the clock situation james even if
this maybe a dubious or potentially a sacrifice
of a backfire he's moving very quickly and that's
putting a lot of pressure on levy on the clock
and definitely the the eval bar was sort of in
levy's favor there because of bishop takes a1 the
computer is always going to just you know grab
that material robert and take it right to the bank
and say yeah no worries we win these but a human
is going to look at that and be like wait a minute
like i can't give away my dark square bishop like
that white plays queen takes a1 bishop h6 he
already gets the piece back or he looks back it
looks like a grunfeld type of position right where
you give up the rook on a1 and then go checkmate
the king uh on the king side because that
fianchetto bishop is so important to a defense
on the king side right when you fianchetto the
h6 square and the dark squares become vulnerable
if that bishop disappears so i think you can
just go ahead and take the pawn on b5 if you
were willing to give up your rook on a1 once i
think you should be willing to give it up now
yep and and i think james has got the right
strategy um to to have a chance in this match
robert because what what he's doing is he's
basically playing fast enough that he's been
up on time every game and he's saying look we all
know how impressive levy can be in time scrambles
so just you're gonna have to show me every time
like you're gonna have to consistently perform
um the the way that he did in game one and it's
not gonna happen every game there's going to be a
few games where levy's going to maybe make some
blunders in time pressure and james has got to
capitalize when that moment happens absolutely
but right now i see the eval bar dip a bit and
i can understand why because in this position
black can take on c4 take on f3 and at the end
of it all white is gonna play g2 takes f3 and the
king side pawn structure is shattered and that's
not what james wanted here so it's interesting
he spent a minute and five seconds and then
said i'm gonna shy away from the exchange
sacrifice i need to keep my material so
it feels like he had the right plan and then he
went away from it because something spooked him
and i i'm not that much of a hater uh on
this position like let's say everything takes
take here you take with a g pawn your bishop
goes to b4 guards your weak pawn hits e7 you
got your rook exactly where it needs to be on d1
and you sort of play king g2 queen e4 rookie one i
can really get behind this position for for white
actually and he started with bishop b4 interesting
oh i like that move because now you're at least
keeping it tactical and the pawn on d5 should not
be captured i think that would be it has to be bad
right some kind of just queen 64 even those pins
the bishop one g4 is under attack in addition to
knight on d5 being under attack so levy has a lot
to calculate he's now down to 20 seconds and he
plays c3 that's a brave move yeah in the face of
as you mentioned a lot of tactics there's h3
i was going to say which i think he might whip
out here if takes takes he wants to play d6 and
suddenly it's it's the rook on a8 that's actually
hanging into the white's bishop and of course if
you get the bishop pair and then the open e file
you put a work on e1 and well that opponent's
c3 it is a pass pawn but it's easy to blockade
for the moment you can just put your queen on
c2 and stop that pawn's progress but not a move
you want to play d6 and five seconds for levy
yeah takes takes queen c7 i think has to be the
the way to go but then there's rook c6 and you're
looking at all right c6 the bishop on f3 yeah well
t take that for sure you got to just grab that
with the rook what's he wearing he's thinking of
bishop case okay queen c7 rook c6 has to be good
yep and this pawn on c3 is going to be strong but
that is material it is but that dark square bishop
will help your light square bishop will help
blockade the pawn so he wait take one take on g7
g7 yeah you go up a piece have you blundered yeah
and the two bishops should win this game and i was
mentioning that's the strategy for canty you gotta
try to use the the pressure of the clock and with
1.8 seconds this is looking tough you only get
one extra second per move not two yeah and you
saw levy's face when he allowed bishop takes g7
he's just like you know and that's what happens
when you're in time trouble more than anything
of course james played a very nice tactical game
but levy didn't have the time he needed to work
through this rook takes c3 get rid of that pass
pawn you're before peace i think we'll throw in
the towel oh yeah this is looking really tough
the bishop controls this um like basically you
could put a black bishop somewhere on the board
and white would probably still be better yeah we
dig d7 that's another free piece and interesting
that he's playing on do you think he's just trying
to waste more time as we head you know um i don't
i don't think he's wasting time i think maybe he's
just feeling out like how confident is james and
putting away these positions like how good is he
maybe when his time gets a little low how good is
he at converting these games and i think what we
saw there was he's pretty confident at converting
yeah especially up a piece james is way too strong
not to be able to win that position but levy goes
for his a3 against the sicilian and of course levy
puts out a ton of content on various openings
this has been an opening that he has used before
but at the highest levels you don't see it
very often because you're playing on the wing
whereas in the opening you often want to play in
the center so b4 at some moment will be a thematic
pawn sacrifice i'm it's just interesting to me
amanda maybe you could speak to this better like
why is he playing a kind of offbeat opening and
then spending time after it yeah it's it's uh i
guess it's something i somehow relate to basically
sometimes when you play an offbeat opening
you have a few variations that someone might play
or maybe that you're expecting them to play it's
quite possible that even though he's playing an
offbeat opening he could have checked what uh
canty plays and he's trying to play against it and
maybe james just played something new something
different or maybe he played one of those testing
lines against the opening the problem with offbeat
lines robert is they usually have either a
refutation or at least a really good reply
so sometimes you play it hoping that the your
opponent does not play the absolute best thing
and when they do you're kind of like ah damn it
you know my my tricks are aren't working here
wow and a humongous raid to uh this broadcast
here thank you so much uh there wow hicaro raid
and of course gotham chess levy rosman he is
often found on hikaru's channel so thank you for
that huge raid and well for all of you i'm sure
many of you are rooting on levy rosman he is in a
tough match right now it's one to one james canty
scores a victory in game two to even the score
and in game three what amon and i have been
talking about is that hey it's an offbeat opening
levy spent some time now it's james's turn because
he's an unfamiliar territory himself and i would
play a6 just to kick that's not a b5 because when
someone plays something like this against me i'm
concerned that there's some tactic that i'm going
to overlook so let me just kick tonight and james
does just that yeah and welcome to all the raiders
i think levy more than anyone is going to be happy
you guys are here because he just had a tough loss
in this match so he's gonna need some energy and
support to get back in this thing for sure and you
were saying that hey you want to get out to a good
start and not have to rely on your bullet skills
that is what levy did in the first game he won he
was feeling confident after that now after game
two you lose the momentum may swing a little bit
the other way and what is happening here in game
three the bishop pair once again for james canty
but those bishops especially that light square
bishop right now doesn't have anywhere nice to go
yeah i i actually really like um levy's opening
might not look like much black has the two bishops
you've actually seen that story in this match
before but levy's bishop is going to get out to
f4 g5 he's going to go you know queen something
like queen d2 and whether he castles uh long or
short i think he should probably castle queenside
the rooks are just going to come to the center of
the board and you don't see many positions in
chess where the two central pawns don't move
and you you sort of have a good position with the
black pieces like you generally do have to take
the center at some point and yeah just playing the
center here with a move like d6 that doesn't feel
right because then he plays d5 but we can see all
these exchanges take place where you take ampisant
right the pawn move two squares and for now you
can take it as if it moved one so you take on d6
you can trade queens on d6 and that pawn on
d6 that remains will be a backwards pawn which
i wouldn't be so thrilled about but james says
i've assessed my odds here i have to go with this
otherwise i'm going to be dominating the center
there we go and that was one of the that was one
of the most interesting first time experience for
me we had a hikara raid and then he carved started
up his stream again maybe what we're doing are we
like viewer farming right now so fifteen thousand
viewer raid hikaru streams we're gonna get fifteen
thousand more viewers that will rate him again
and we'll just keep doing that robert i like the
cycle let's go hey you know that that works for
us and of course for many of you who are tuning in
as fans of both of these content creators and we
welcome all of you so we see that james is king
now sitting on e7 not very well placed with a
rook coming to e1 with check for example but he
puts the bishop on e6 he can move his king out
of the way and it still feels to me that despite
the double c pawns that white should be slightly
better i'm just not quite sure how to prove it
yeah and i think the nice thing to look forward to
um in any type of end game here is that uh it
might not look like much but just the presence
of those two pawns indicates that black spawns are
generally going to be stuck on light squares and
this light square bishop isn't going to have any
targets to attack if white just plays g3 it's like
imagine an end game this bishop is just dancing
around these bonds but can't attack them
so i i feel like levy is is going to be happy with
uh getting an endgame finally a less tactical game
you know he can sort of calm down a bit
he's got the white pieces he's not down
uh that much on time right now so i think
he's gonna be happy just to have a chill game
robert to sort of break the momentum i'm with
you but there is something frustrating about
knowing that you have a slightly better position
but not really on not necessarily understanding
but not finding a way to capitalize on it and
i think that's what's happening right here
at least from my point of view white is better you
have a knight against a bishop why does the knight
become better than a bishop in a position like
this then knight can just sit on a dark square
the bishop can do nothing to attack it but where
is the follow-up i think king d7 makes sense here
that way you avoid the pin that the pawn c4 then
really becomes under attack and if you have your
d6 pawn under attack you just put your king on c7
so you just run your king to safety and i don't
know i'm not really seeing where white is going
to make progress from no that's i think in a uh
in a classical game you know that this wouldn't
be anything to to write home but in a blitz game
sometimes these advantages are often a little bit
more pronounced um than than you might think so
um we'll see how the game develops but i certainly
agree there it shouldn't really be anything
here for for levy but you know he's he's got a
slightly better position and it depends really
how comfortable he is grinding down these small
advantages some players as as you know robert
are specialists there that's their kind of chess
and some players are they just wish the position
had a queen on it and it was more tactical yeah
there are definitely people with those preferences
and well b3 played to defend the c4 pawn
now 94 check rook e to d3 come to mind
as a way to hit upon dark square we talk
about the problem with a bishop it can't
protect pieces on the opposite color and so that
d6 pawn cemented backwards that's going to be a
problem for james i didn't really like to move
king f6 i feel like he's moving his king away
from a lot of the action on the queen side yeah
i think he was maybe a little bit scared to play
king d7 just because it looks funny like walking
into the rooks so he wants to get out of the way
but i think king d7 was actually the better move
and b5 has been played which if that gets taken
a takes b5 we're going to have an imbalance where
in an end game there is going to be an outside a
pawn might not look like much right now but that
could be the the major difference in the position
for sure because that pawn you can use as a decoy
distract black's pieces that have to deal with
that running passer and then white can operate on
the other side of the board so rook f3 check is
played and well i see two options one is bishop
f5 just blocking the check with your bishop you
can't play g4 because that pawn on h5 that's the
good news about that pawn being on h5 and honestly
king g7 he played looks fine as well rook to d3
you probably just played d5 and protect your palm
yeah the weird thing about that position is i was
actually feeling pretty confident that bishop f5
was one of the better moves um there was no g4
as you mentioned and bishop f5 also opens up
rook e2 next hitting c2 and just getting on the
second rank and if white goes something like
rook d2 it just feels like white is
somehow assuming the uh slightly more
passive role at the moment i'm with you
and gotta shout out tree poker for gifting
tons of subs we really appreciate that uh
thank you for your support of chess and the
channel so appreciate it and he's not even done
he's gifting more subs as we're thanking him
thanks a lot tree poker very kind oh
that's awesome and look at this we have uh
an end game with two rooks per side white no
longer has those double pawns black no longer
is suffering with a questionable bishop against
a good knight so this feels like a position where
it should be a hold but amount of keeping your
idea in the back of my mind that outside a pawn
has me preferring white's position in the long run
okay and i'll take the other side and and present
not only the maybe one minute time advantage
i think that's going to be a bit relevant
but also that black's weak pawn can be defended
kind of nicely by king e7 the king's in the center
of the board and you know if if black ever attacks
this a pawn white's king has to go pretty far
to the queen side and might leave the center
exposed so the nice thing about using the king
to defend one of your weak pawns is suddenly it
frees up one of the rooks suddenly rookie 2 rookie
4 or rook 88 are all possible but i do think that
the clock is something we need to pay attention
to because unfortunately it was the detriment
of levy in that last game you had a great game
but i mentioned levy's great under time pressure
but he's not going to be great every single game
absolutely and g3 played so levi has 18 seconds
left he could consider b4 actually now that i
look at the position just to try to get to the b5
pawn where the rook on d5 looks very promising and
james has no fear he's just pushing his pawns
forward he can even consider f4 at some point
as black to give away a pawn than to ruin
the pawn structure that remains for white
absolutely and levy's going for this position
where he says look my rook defends my pawn and
my pawn defends my pawn my pawn defense my pawn is
nothing you know that that's left loose uh in this
position and then as we've been mentioning a pawn
runs to the end of the board in any type of king
and pawn end game so 14 seconds to 30 seconds
time is evening up here i think the evaluation
is around equal but i have a feeling someone's
gonna win this game robert well i don't like
what's happening with levy's clock he's down to
seven seconds and when you play an end game like
this which may seem just completely docile
it's an even position nothing to worry about
then you look at your clock you freak out make
a quick move and your position becomes worse
by the time i think you should consider b4 that's
the move i keep looking at for white trying to
change the pawn structure and use that rook on d5
to your advantage and look at that there we go and
there the rook comes in i think rook e4 intending
maybe f4 is the way to go but this is good as well
and i'm really looking at that outside a pawn
now yeah so what levy wants to do is he wants
to get his king up put his rook behind that
pawn and try to push it as far as it'll go
and win the king and pawn end game canty has to
be very careful here in my opinion oh certainly
because this is one of those positions where
it looks completely even and you lose because
of the outside pawn imagine the rooks are off the
board oh this is bad this is getting bad rook d2
next already looks a bit sketchy yep and here king
d4 rook d2 check the good news is the king needs
to stay on b4 to protect a5 so it won't be able to
take that's a good move yeah that's a great move
king e4 and now king d3 or kd4 okay c3 you're
gonna stack c2 just place okay this still works
king e2 maybe king d2 but he's gotta make movies
last time oh no oh my gosh robert i just had this
terrible feeling that someone was gonna lose
this game it's a draw it's equal evaluation but
it requires so much accuracy and wow wow that's
exactly what levy needed if you're in the lobby
rosman camp i mean you're definitely cheering
for that result but just tragic for kante who
played a great game robert and lost it at the very
end on time and in the words of james candy's hat
that's not a move you had to make a move and this
is on time oh my gosh that is so heartbreaking and
we're about to go into our break the players
get to take a little bit of rest but that
must feel horrible as you head into this
break you're going to try to recover from it
but it was great defense that whole game by
james canty the third and then you lose on
the clock that is i'm sorry to say devastating
for team danny it is now as devastating as that
is robert as we head into our break james has
to remember that he's only down one game and
when we come back there's gonna be the rest of the
five minute portion for sure and for all you out
there who are fans of these great content creators
gotham chess and jim canty we will be right back
in a few minutes for more action from the i'm
not gm speeches championship brought to you by
chess.com
and we return getting ready for more five-minute
plus one-second increment games from this i'm
not gm speed just championship match
between gotham chess and gm canty
amman canty still must be hurting he must
be reeling after losing on time in that game
how can he recover yeah i robert i think it's
really important for canty here to not let the
emotions get the better of him i don't know what
type of player he is uh in terms of controlling
his emotions and how much a loss might affect him
going into the next game i think that's kind of
a question mark for a lot of us uh he seems like
you know so chill so vibin when when he's playing
um and before the match so if he has that same
type of energy i think that's exactly what he
needs right now just put it behind him you know i
think he's already maybe over performing from what
some people thought going into this match it's two
to one and he's maybe had a chance to win almost
every game uh in this match so far roberts i think
he's doing great and he needs to remind himself of
that i think it's an excellent point because when
you come as the underdog you need to believe that
you can do it and based on the three games we've
seen thus far he should believe that he can do
it he has been every step of the way in these
games he has you know lost the first game then
just lost this last game on time but he is clearly
a worthy competitor and somebody who can challenge
a great player in gotham chess and right now candy
gets the white pieces again we'll see this pan off
maybe james looked at it during the break that is
the benefit of having a break is you can improve
on what you did in previous games yeah and it's
recommended even uh that's that's what a lot of
the players use and should use that brake force
we'll see if canty has looked at this we saw that
this was kind of pivotal in a lot of other matches
at least that i've commentated in this i'm not a
gm tournament so far it's like you use that break
to actually double check the line check it with an
engine oh if this opening didn't go well last time
what critical mistake did i make and let's simply
change that for the upcoming round so both players
are looking to repeat this i understand why levy's
repeating hey you worked fantastic last time he's
gonna take that position every game but canty if
he's repeating this he better have something new
prepared and look what we see on the board bishop
f3 that is a new move exactly he's protecting the
d5 pawn with the bishop on a safer square remember
that last game where knight a6 knight c7 and then
b5 just made white's pieces feel uncomfortable
that bishop on f3 you're not attacking that
good luck to you and so now the knight can
come to e2 and maybe even eventually to f4 to
make that pawn on d5 feel extra nicely defended
yep and bishop f3 i think is the move
that i've seen a little bit more often
so kante basically just changed one single move
but he's basically he's gonna go with the same
setup that's the nice thing it doesn't change
that much about what he knows about the position
but he is playing a move that the engine prefers
here so small adjustment and it could make all
the difference here as he once again has jumped
out to that early lead robert what do you make
of this ante always seems to be up on the clock
yeah in the early stages that has been the case
and even actually later in the game but that's
worries me a bit for the three minute portion
if i'm a gotham chess fan because then you
don't have all this time to spend in the early
part of the game but here he plays a move b5 this
is thematic where you give up another pawn that's
a pawn that's not defended so white can grab it
in two different ways but the point is the quick
activity that black is able to obtain for the cost
of another pawn is worth it there's a king on e1
not yet ready to castle yeah that's a great point
and the funny thing about a move like b5 is it
kind of walks into d6 uncovering the bishop's
attack of the rook but you just sidestep that
attack and say yeah go ahead and take my opponent
e7 i'll be more than happy to develop with check
yeah it's one of these positions where it's all
about that king being the center because normally
d6 would be a great move where you're using one of
your doubled isolated pawns and trading it off for
a healthy pawn e7 but it opens the e file without
a pawn there that's gonna backfire a4 i mean
levy's just no respect for his own pawns it feels
like here robert he's just chucking them left
right and center you know he pro the apon probably
saw levy grab that b-pawn and then suddenly he was
off the board and he sees him reaching for the
a-pawn he's like oh no it's my turn you know if
i'm benny watts i'm taking my nice little caracon
matcha back because he says all pawns no hope levy
says no pawns i'll hope and look at him go here
he wants to go after the center and i wouldn't be
surprised if like e6 was possible there saying you
know take my pawn e6 i'm opening the file up your
king still sits on anyone whatever just chuck them
all to the wayside and bishop b7 knight back to c3
by canty and we actually see a similar position to
last game but that bishop on f3 it just has to be
better placed there for sure it's just much more
stable it can't be attacked white is going to play
knight g1 to e2 so i can see where the play comes
from for levy he can play knight c7 go after the
opponent d5 but white's moves are also pretty
easy to spot knight e2 castle move your queen
away when it gets under attack so i i don't
see the entire compensation for two sacrifice
pawns you will likely regain one back but i don't
think it's sufficient for true equality there's
some dynamic play that black has but i would
prefer to have james's position at this point
yep no and he's he's played it again he's up more
than a minute here and if you're up more than a
minute and you're up a pawn the worst that's
going to happen most likely is you lose maybe
that pawn back so i think i think you should be i
think you should be uh happy with what we see here
and that's one of the things that i think boggs
players down myself included where is that if
i've given up material and i see a way to cut
that deficit from two pawns in one pawn i'm like
wait then what i'm still down a pawn and you start
allowing that to weigh on you and you need to play
dynamically and you need to play quickly look at
james canty once again up a minute and 40 plus
almost two minutes like i i just want to speak
on maybe the time management because this is so
relatable for me uh usually when you're a player
that is confident in your bullet skills and we
know levy you know rocking that 2850 bullet
rating when you're confident in your bullet
skills and you know how good of a time scrambler
you are how good at making up deficits you are
sometimes when you see your clock ticking down
145 you're like whatever you know when i have
five seconds like you know i'm a god like i can
handle that but you don't need to put yourself
in that position usually you want to have those
skills reserved for when you need them and then
you know you can show up and and save a tough
position but you don't want to be getting
in that in that type of time pressure every
single game it's so easy to let that happen
when you see this time and you're like yeah you
know it's no problem i'm a good bullet player
yeah i'm completely with you and i'm looking at
the time spent on queen b6 black's last move levy
spent a minute and 43 seconds on knight g to e2
james only spent 18.6 seconds and this is the type
position where white is better over the board
but his biggest advantage may be on the clock
as he is up so much time here and black
doesn't have clear access to saying i've
made up for the fact that i'm down a bunch of
pawns it's not a clear position so time is so
important absolutely and and even after the move
queen a2 which might not be the preferred move
maybe he goes queen d3 but just looking at queen
a2 like let's say you go greedy that depon's
defended on d5 the d-pawn on d4 is defended the
knight can't get into b4 or c5 and you're castling
next turn it it just feels like uh like you got
to put the appropriate weight on being up about
two minutes here like that that's an advantage
and that's part of the game and the pawn a4
that's a loner so even if you go pile up pressure
on the d pawn on one of those pawns you may drop
your pawn on the a file so i would just play queen
a2 then i would castle pretty much no matter what
black does and say prove it prove that you have
what it takes to come back from a two pawn deficit
especially when you are down so much time yeah
probably knight c7 i'm trying to come up with
another move but knight's d7 looks like it and
levy has played queen b6 rook c8 but neither of
those moves actually contribute to getting that
d-pawn back so i'm wondering what his plan is
with those moves is he someone going to use the
pieces like the knight on a6 looks like he can
only go to c7 i'm wondering what his plan is in
the next couple of moves robert that's frustrating
right you want to play knight c7 queen d6 and you
realize that even if you get those two moves then
bishop f4 can be a response the knight on he2 can
go to f4 itself but it defends that square so the
bishop would be able to develop with tempo queen
b3 trading off queens when you're down two pawns
maybe it's all right but i would be very reluctant
to do something like that yep and uh one important
thing which i think levy's relying on is that his
knight might get into the action with knight b4
using that pin on the a file knight d3 check
knight c2 check it's all about takes takes and
levy wants to play knight before so keep an eye on
that james can look to prevent that with like rook
b1 afterwards or he could just develop his pieces
and say look you know you can have that knight in
you can have that square i'm still up two pawns
yeah i think he should trade queens but maybe he
doesn't have to because what is black's threat
are you really just going to take on a2 that
doesn't scare him so he actually castles that's
probably the better option it doesn't give levy
those tactics that you were just talking about him
on so with 30 seconds to two minutes prove it and
i think this is a great strategy by james in this
game you lost game three on time now in game four
you keep saying you prove it you show me that you
can have sufficient compensation for the material
and queen c2 i mean this has got to be in uh james
favor here the bishop can just develop and after
the bishop develops i mean the rook just slides
over to c1 i don't see any issues in the position
here for james i i mean take your pick about where
you want to develop that bishop to but rick c1
rookie one rook d1 are coming i i like what james
has got going on here yeah and all with tempo
right so bishop g5 perhaps just to try to even
take on that he was bishop e3 that's more solid i
like that as you said rook c1 rook d1 that knight
can go to f4 if you attack d5 again i can't get
behind this position uh i think that it's just too
much trouble for levy especially with 12.7 seconds
and i think levy is planning to go queen f5 if he
gets attacked queen back to d7 at least reclaim
that d-pawn and then go from there but bishop b3
is a nice move because it watches d4 and as you
mentioned it lets knight f4 happen watching d5 so
everything's covered here um in kante's position
okay so now knight h5 was the first one
that came to my mind once you push upon you
sort of relinquish control over the
square that it previously was covering
so knight h5 trades some pieces it also removes an
attacker of the d5 pawn the g5 pawn itself is weak
because it's bishop on e3 so i think that's
a pretty good move to make and keep in mind
there's also d6 as a threat hitting f7 long range
and the knight in that position after knight takes
h5 bishop h5 so it even works out there yeah and
he's spending a lot of time this is actually what
got him into trouble in previous games where
the position is complicated and that he went
too low on the clock and he's probably thinking
do i throw in rook c1 he does so queen f5 looks
like the only real option automatic move and i
don't think that inclusion benefits canty because
now knight h5 let's say takes takes there's
maybe g4 and yeah so he's going to go knight g3
bishop back to e bishop d1 might actually be an
interesting move i really like bishop d1 because
you go bishop c2 and take over the f5 square for
your knight i think he's gonna go rook d1 bishop
d3 same idea bring that knight in and he does
yeah and bishop d3 traps the queen actually oh my
goodness right it looks like you're just trying
to take the f5 square but the queen is trapped
so queen b1 yeah queen b1
b1 and it hits the bishop
that's that's game over if he plays
queen b1 wow i played that that flags
oh my goodness it's that plus one robert
so deceptive that's barely enough time to
register the move and make one of your own well
can we just bring up that position again because
that was wild f3 is such a dangerous move to
play because you're opening up your own king
so we would take that instinctively and maybe
just h4 right right taking advantage of the pin
hitting the knight and all of a sudden in a
time scramble if levy gets those two moves off
like take this pre-move h4 you've got yourself a
game here exactly so james really was playing with
fire there it works out in his favor and as we get
into uh this new game here i mean it's trumpowski
attack so we're getting obscure not so obscure but
less popular openings and james is once again up a
pawn but his queen is a niffy spot in the center
of the board could be attacked many times i think
that levy is just relying on the active play and
james has been taking what levy's been giving him
so far yeah that's exactly that's a good great way
to put it is that james is sitting there saying
look you're gonna play these offbeat openings
against me they're not topped here for a reason
i'm going to go ahead and take the material
you know give me the material and you prove
that you know this is crushing for for you what
we have here is as you mentioned the trumpowski
i think this is a fun line for white to play so i
kind of like levy's position but that's just been
the story the whole time levy has had a lot of fun
positions to play with compensation but james just
keeps taking that material and saying all right
prove it you know i'm gonna take these all match
i think the most troubling sign for me is that
levy spends a lot of time after playing these
uh openings because when you it's a part of it is
the surprise factor when you play something that
is not standard you're relying on that you know
it better and that you will be able to make the
most quickly so you'll get that lead on the clock
but that has not been the case james has been able
to meet these openings with quick responses and
he's playing quite well you know right out of the
gate so it is concerning for levy as we continue
here is a 2-2 match but amman justify the pawn
sacrifice for me white is down a pawn tell me
why i should approve of white's position here
yeah i mean especially after d6 the if you have d6
e5 against the bishop like a london bishop let's
call it or a bishop on this diagonal h2 to b8
you're already feeling good because that bishop's
completely blunted there's nothing going on here
h6 uh even covers g5 in this position i mean
you're just hoping for bishop d3 and and trying
to chase that queen but you know even if you waste
a lot of time maybe three moves in a row bringing
that queen back the problem is robert we've got a
closed position and closed positions are exactly
where you can let's say quote unquote waste
time like that or make a bunch of moves that don't
complete your development if this position was
wide open i'd be a lot more concerned for canteen
completely agreed and the idea for white is maybe
bishop d3 but the queen's not trapped because
you have the g4 square and now there's a bit of
a problem because the h pawn would like to go back
to h3 there no can't happen and knight d7 clever
play by james bishop d3 now met by queen takes
d5 which was not possible before because there
would have been a check discovery a fossil if you
will and the queen would have been hanging on d5
yeah no that's exactly right and time and
time again canty just takes the material and
runs away with it basically and it's up to levy
to to prove this i don't think he's in a terrible
position this is still you know well within the
realm of what position you can expect from this
line um he might want to go queen b3 a4a5 knight
d2 or bishop d3 always kick the queen out right
i'm with you man and i think here now that queen
should probably say my stay has been excellent but
i'm no longer welcome on the e4 square it feels
like if you leave it there too long bishop d3
will hurt you especially if you make the move
bishop g4 which looks like a very natural move
then bishop e3 traps your queen on the spot it's
true that that would be a terrible thing to do a
terrible thing so probably just castle would be my
move you still always have the g4 squad escape too
um the other thing that's kind of uh yeah a5
i was just gonna say after knight d7 you can
almost play like knight takes e5 and bishop d3
trapping the queen once again oh no the g2 pawn
hangs oh it's so close oh man so maybe you should
throw in like work the sneaky no idea what you're
doing with rick h2 exactly yeah don't mind
me uh just look over there for a sec buddy
yeah this is any castles and but by the way levy
is now ahead of the clock we made a big deal about
james has been the one up on time throughout the
match right now levy does have quite a substantial
lead on time however he's down a pawn i don't see
the clear compensation and a big problem for white
is where you're going to castle if you cast a
king side the only way you can legally castle now
you sort of regret having your pawn on h4 as your
king side is a little bit more vulnerable and it's
a it's actually really impressive that james is
able to leave his queen on e4 for so long i i just
couldn't do it i would just look at that queen and
be like no no i'm about to get trapped something's
gonna go horribly wrong here i'm so scared
of these like night triggs to trap the queen
but james says look i mean it doesn't work you
know just calculate that out those are concrete
calculations and it looks like he's made them
here yeah and i'm looking at the players right now
james is locked in like he no longer is seated he
is just fully focused head right at the computer
screen and this is his chance right he's probably
feeling that that hey i was down two games to one
after losing on time now look at this it's 2-2
i'm up a pawn i know i'm ahead on the clock
my queen's not getting trapped thankfully so f5
comes to mind for black in the near future be very
careful here if you are levy because this position
can get quite bad in the near future but h5 played
taking away some squares from that queen and
maybe there's a rook h4 type of idea in the
future and it's fine levy to also looks locked in
like these guys both look like they're calculating
really really hard right now the problem is what
you're seeing is james is calculating where he
knows that he probably has the upper hand things
are sort of going to work in his favor that's
how chess generally works if you feel you
have slightly better position the tactics
often work for you whereas levy's calculating like
a guy who wants to make things work he's trying to
find the trickier ways to play and the ways that
candy might slip up yeah and i said this at the
top of the show is that you cannot play chess for
a result because then you're distracted you're not
being objective and chess is a very objective game
so if you have results or into thinking you aren't
playing your best chess and look at this a trade
of bishops here you would like to get bishop b3 in
very quickly and then put your knight on f5 but
bishop d3 would always be met by pawn to e4 and
maybe e4 now is good for black put that knight on
e5 and just take over the board i agree i agree f5
i think this move is also playable but what
i don't like is that that queen robert not to
give you flashbacks but no queen on h7 knight
g6 i mean let's just say the coffin over here
i see what you did there and you know you
wanted to remind me of what happened to
my queen when we were playing the chess com chess
bro match but you're right that even if knight g6
isn't the immediate move and levy doesn't play i
think it was smart to hold back from it you just
created weaknesses for yourself that you're going
to have to look at move after move and now we're
back to a situation levy a bit ahead in the clock
he's finally ready to castle if he wants to and
where is james going from here i think e4
should be played e4 trying to get your knight
d5 plays rook f7 and the funny thing about the
position is although levy might be down a pawn
believe me it's going to be a long time before
that matters look at that extra pawn it's on b7
there's no queen side play to speak of um this
game is all about the king side and hey the pawns
are equal on the king side so i think i think
uh canty by the way played rook f7 for knight f8
he did not like knight g6 so he wanted to be able
to remove that piece when it comes out in fact he
might play knight f8 right away but he might not
like the look of g4 at some moment probably not
now and he plays knight fade to allow a trade on
g4 and the rook on f7 also protects g7 so you are
making sure that in the event the g-file
opens up you're not just going to get
a blistering checkmate on the square so i
do approve this i think maybe you should
use that extra pawn you mention it it's not
doing anything at some point play b6 what
g5 and it's not that it's terrible it's
just insane i did not see that coming right
that might be a good move though he's like
levy i heard you were trying to play g4 well
sorry buddy i got there first wow that is
a move and wow and takes takes first of all
it's important to note that if everybody takes
and you go bishop h5 looking to win material
don't forget that little sneaky check uh james
is not about to drop material there wow that
is an awesome move we're gonna have to remember
to ask james about this moment uh that was real
i don't even care about the result that's just
to even think about g5 and that's the hardest
part it's once it's played you're like oh actually
that makes a lot of sense but to even think about
it during a game when you have under a minute
on the clock that's phenomenal stuff and i like
his position all of a sudden oh man the knights
coming to e4 he's flipping this around completely
and the time is even now in fact it's swinging
in canty's favor what a brilliant move that is
i am still in shock and as i try to look at the
position as it unfolds here you said knight f6
can come to e4 or even to g4 depending on what
happens uh this bishop can develop rook to e8 take
over the e file the white king is not safe no king
f2 there's always like a g4 at some point in queen
d4 check just always have to consider that that
knight is coming straight into e4 and now that the
king's on f1 yup can't take that oh boy and levi
probably underestimated that he was previously
with the king on e1 probably planning to take and
where does that queen even go if you go to the e
file rookie 8 then there's knight discoveries
to win the queen on the e file this is i mean
you can't just take back takes g5 yeah exactly
my goodness what a game but james canty wow wow
yeah it looks logical but i mean g4 is a rookie
eight first like hello let's start with that
because h6 isn't a okay he won't quench him
because he was worried about h6 i guess but that
wasn't actually that concerning and james needs to
move more quickly we've seen him throw away decent
positions good positions in time trouble he's
under 20 seconds and he has been the one who has
faltered when the clock starts dwindling i don't
mind this move queen h6 but he needs a rook on the
e file it's it's been too long with that one and
now maybe it doesn't even work because it's queen
g5 it takes a quick g5 but queen should we trade
everything is knight trapped no it's not as the
h3 square it's got e6 as well let's say if need
be but yeah you're right yeah there's also each
h3 so he grabs the pawn and it was e3 i think
that james is in great position look at that
move rookie for winning a c4 pawn but levy can't
complain we saw the position he previously had
you can't complain with what you got here no this
is by far the best oh and the rook should went to
the d file i think take on e6 rookie four game
over because all pawn end games are going to be
winning for black oh i don't love that move but
you've got to be careful yep oh so e6 hang on c3
is winning on the spot c3 c2 so take on h6 you're
up three pawns over here oh i don't like that move
you should not let the king come back on this
way i think levy oh it's close quincy five so
i think this is probably winning two pawns is
i think technically a draw but there's no way
he's gonna have time to set it up no and there's
also that extra pawn just in case like i don't
know if that matters but it could it's a rookie
two game over king a1 don't take it don't take
it don't take that rook a3 that's that's smart
nice try though by levy that was pretty very nice
and don't play rook b2 because that puts
the king on a stalemate so do not play
i don't like that check check yes nice nice move
these guys are both playing really well here yeah
they really like c1 intended you gotta go rook
b8 or right side c3 just push that pawn i think
okay only rook check king e3 oh and king c1 just
what a wild position no no what no the could you
steal me oh my god rook takes you too it wasn't
it doesn't work anymore oh what the hell my gosh
what the hell was that oh that end game must have
fluctuated from winning to to draw so many times
and levy was using the chess tactic desperado
where the position on the board is a draw except
for one piece that you have so you take that piece
and you say hey over here take me take me pick me
okay and eventually he had to that was one of
the most exhilarating games i've been a part of
first of all i'm not going to forget about james
candy's g5 that was a stellar move and then you
have to just say you know what levy rosin with
amazing awareness of the fact that there could be
stalemates he was losing that end game for sure
but he found it just in time and james in time
trouble once again that's been his kryptonite just
insane what a crazy crazy game that the poor eval
bar robert just got the biggest workout of the
day yeah it's very true it was swinging up and
down real fast and by the way i haven't been able
to make fun of the opening choice here because the
scandy i'm sure greg shahadi a participant in this
tournament is laughing about the scandinavian but
we did see a scandi and that's why levy's queen's
in the center as we get to the current position
and james should be very happy once again yeah
he's got a very very standard uh very standard
type of position here in c4 queen h5 played yeah
can't complain here if you're candy gotta watch
it for a little trick here bishop takes h2 with
the pin on the knight there but h3 covers that
yeah and white just has more space has two pawns
uh out on the fourth rank none of black's pieces
besides the queen are past your own third rank
so easy development coming for white i would
much prefer james's position and so levy will have
to figure this out on his own here and he's also
down and building the clock yeah how about that
that last game like in terms of what it means
for the players i feel like levy almost treats
that game like a win like that's how it must feel
he made an insane comeback from like a dead lost
position and and then yeah it probably feels that
way to him whereas james knows that he was he was
winning that game and threw it away at the end
yeah and he you saw his face he was pretty
devastated by the fact that he didn't win that
game he could have gone ahead in this match and
what he needs to do is just look at the position
that he has on the board right now his position is
good right he has a new game this is good i didn't
like the move c5 because that leaves a hole in
the d5 square and leaves you with his pawn on d4
that is kind of backwards but he says i'm going to
put my bishop on f4 and take advantage of kicking
my opponent's bishop out so he has a good position
that's my ultimate point he should take a breath
just look here at this game and play as if it's
zero to zero because it's a time match and what
happens on uh knight takes like is it is it worth
just full simplification takes takes takes on c7
and and try to try to go for that position
bishop h2 he doesn't want to yeah he didn't
want to drop the d4 pawn but i'm with you that
that looked pretty good i guess he's saying hey
please do take me on c3 because when i take back
with the b pawn your c7 pawn is under attack
my d4 pawn is strengthened and the b file will
be open for my rook so instead levy smartly
plays bishop f6 and i expect some kind of just
rook d1 to rick fd1 i guess to defend the pawn
yep one of those rooks to d1 it's going to be
the a brook so in case the the e file i mean
it is a semi-open file for white so rook f2e1 is
going to make some sense in the future and canty
uh you know don't forget opening up that around
30 second time advantage early on in these games
it might not look relevant right now when these
players have so much time you know relative to
the the blitz that everyone plays nowadays but
that 30 seconds if these guys play at the same
pace suddenly it's 30 seconds when when the guy
has you know 10 seconds to 40 and it means it
means the world i'm with you a nice look at
the eval bar it says that white's slightly
ever so slightly better but from my point of
view here it just seems easier to play for
white i actually don't see what black's plan
is exactly and a3 why can't try to play b4
it feels like even if it's not concretely that
good for white it just i'm threatening something
it looks like i'm threatening something and you're
gonna have to deal with that move after move yep
this knight tied down to that c7 pawn keep in
mind if that c7 pawn just drops for any reason
the d6 square is gone and black's position just
collapses a hundred percent i'm also just looking
at that queen and saying okay you know i just
always have to be cognizant of the fact that it
doesn't have a lot of squares left on the board to
move to so you know some type of attacks g4 and a
g3 in the right moment when things are protected
uh could could put the question of that queen
i'm with you again and i mean i'm looking at
this position what is black's planet it looked
like e5 was what you wanted to do but that's not
happening not with a knight on f3 a bishop on h2
the pawn on d4 on the queen and the rook on the
e file so i would probably move my queen away
to make queen c2 queen b3 comes to mind as
a way to just poke and prod at black's queen
side over there and as you're pointing out
the queen on h5 just doesn't have the same
power and the same access to better squares and
it's important to know knight takes f6 check
levees absolutely recapturing with the g pawn
not only because he needs to protect c7 but also
because i think it's a good move anyways it covers
the e5 square and it opens a dangerous chi file
uh to white's king that's definitely true and the
knight on d5 is so powerful and a light square
it's the entire reason i did not like when james
went c5 because you give your opponent a square
and now you have this pawn on d4 that's stuck in
place so i think levy's honestly playing this very
well and he's keeping about love on the clock he's
down a little bit but as we've seen if he's the
one lowering the clock he still manages to hold on
despite that time deficit so for now okay i still
am concerned though about how levi's been using
his time yeah what i think levi should do is make
much quicker moves um because i i don't think that
when he's played king h8 the thing is look at that
eval bar after king aj the eval bar barely
changed i don't think levy is is at risk of
making a huge blunder of any sort here so you know
just throw in queen f5 throwing queen g6 king h8
uh rook d7 like just just some small move and and
really get that time on the clock back because
you're looking at laby's position saying well i
don't really know what the guy's going to do but
at the same time he's got a great looking position
right now so he can almost just kind of shuffle
around in a blitz sense you're right and an
important point is rook b3 which i imagine
was james's idea can be met by knight a5 it's a
typical move that defends your pawn on b7 while
attacking the rook and that's necessary because
you do not want to drop that pawn and so it's a
clever response available to levy there yeah
and if james ever gets tempted by the move b4
it might do him more harm than good because you
don't really need to connect these pawns and the
pawn on b2 might not look like it but covering the
c3 square is really important and that's why he
played rook to d3 he wanted queen takes h3 with
some sort of knight move knight e5 hitting the
queen wow james first with g5 now with g4 i don't
really like it that he followed up with knight
takes bishop because you were talking about how
black wanted to take with the pawn of six anyway
and now with the pawn on g4 that becomes a bit
of a target but i think right now he kind of has
to slide his king to h1 i don't like his king the
g5 this this is a position where i think levy is
extremely happy um he's probably going to follow
up with some sort of h5 or maybe f5 probably the h
pawn slide the rook over this knight on d5 what a
monster that you just can't get rid of it well let
me counter this what about some kind of knight
g2 bishop g3 bishop h okay he went knight f3
back but i was wondering if that bishop can slide
out and try to get to the h4 square at some point
i really like the move knight g2 just as an idea
to go to f4 maybe to go to e3 as he said bishop g3
plug the g file with pieces so that it's you know
less of an impact when it gets pried open with h5
yeah and i see the eval bar favoring black but
i would say it's not very easy to prove that but
rook g8 is a step in the right direction rook g1
would be my response because i i see that there's
a queen of rook there trying to open up the file
i don't want that to happen i can play rook g1
as a response to f5 or h5 so that's probably why
he felt no rush to move his rook yeah the rook's
gonna slide over let's see if h5 this knight where
is it trying to go could go to c4 and e3 it could
go to e4 and c3 but i think getting rid of this
knight is definitely a big idea for canty yeah
i would agree with that and i'm trying to think
do i play queen e4 do i offer queen he puts his
knight back on f3 he feels aimless right now
he went knight h4 knight f3 knight d2 knight f3
and he does not mind making a draw because he's
down on the clock and his position looks worse
to my eyes but he hasn't found a plan yet knight
takes up six at some point watch out for that just
maybe not yet in general but the bishop wants
to land on e5 so interesting idea so something
like uh yeah knight there for example rook
f3 knight h4 rook takes f6 and bishop e5
a hundred percent you're right three good yeah and
knight h4 it's easy to blunder that rook takes f6
i don't know if it works but it certainly looks
good following your idea of getting that bishop
to e5 with a sacrifice i think it does work
i mean then you win a pawn and a knight for
the rook and the king is weak the rook and g will
be under attack and i actually don't really know
what black should have f5 what about f5 takes and
knight f4 f5 you're a brave brave guy but you know
yeah maybe can i play queen on f1 at the end of
that like i take your negative queen f1 i say
you're not checkmating me yeah i think that has to
be it and actually that could backfire on levy he
has a number of ways to go wrong here maybe f5 is
not the best maybe net h4 is not the best he goes
e5 of all moves this is going to get wild at the
finish and look at the time 24 seconds left for
levy 25 seconds almost for james he takes the
pawn now the knight's trying to come to f4 so
be careful about that but what does knight
of four actually attack you've given up the
f5 square so knight g3 comes to mind there
it is watch out knight h5 knight five coming
e5 pawn is hanging by the way and he's trying
to bait him in to queen e5 with a rook d1 at
the end and now b7 is hanging you may not have
seen important but that pawn can be captured of
rook d4 for example and that knight is coming
in the game yep in eight seconds oh wow this is
gonna be a crazy finish and i know levy plays
a lot of hyper bullet but you do not want to
be down to 5.8 seconds in this position he plays
f6 knight h5 dangerous move but he has the g-file
under his control with a rook g201 he does and
that that that knight is going to be hanging
on f4 at the end you can trade everything here
that's a really good point trade and take on f4
it's a very good idea he doesn't do it just yet
and levi barely got that move off with something
seconds left oh my goodness queen g4 queen e4
oh gosh that's mata queen takes b7 only move
plus queen of one between e4 no it's over oh
queen takes f6 trick oh great oh you missed it wow
oh i don't know if it was going to be a
draw there but it looked like great chances
queen takes f6 bishop e3 the h-bomb's loose
but it should be a win for levy wow levy's just
proven to be stronger in time trouble that's
that's right now that's where this match is at wow
and he takes it he doesn't want
to risk anything at this point
just don't run your king away too
far because then g5 will win for what
yeah i like c6 by kante you know it looks maybe
irrelevant but hey that's a chance at some point
using the outside h-bond he should be lost
here and levy knows what to do no this is
not going to work the king is in the box and
the king comes back and stops the bomb yep
apon and the g-pawn are going to run
in chesapeake with the gifted subs
a little bit of celebration there as well for uh
levy rosman as he takes the lead in this match
again and this might be the last game of this five
minute portion robert yeah it looks like it will
be because they're under five minutes remaining
and these games have gone a long time and levy
goes back to this variation where james did seem
well prepared he didn't win the game he uncorked
that really brilliant g5 move that we were very
fond of especially me and i don't know if i
approve of going back to this variation what
do you think i'm on um i i think that james is
generally going to be happy to repeat most of the
things that we've seen in this match i'll put it
that way like i think that he's been comfortable
taking these pawns i think it's in his style and i
think that obviously we've got a very close match
here robert i think that it's working out so he's
saying look i might be you know dropping a few of
these games but i'm very happy to keep taking the
material and what he knows is that we haven't had
a break since the last game so it's not like levy
has had time to to check a line or anything like
that um so he knows look the guy is just repeating
the line maybe he'll switch something up but it's
not like he has any new theory after a break maybe
we'll see him uh check the line himself and
the guys might change things up but right now
i think he's fine to repeat yeah and actually i
like this version much more than what happened
in the previous game for levy because at least he
has an aggressive position that queen on e4 looked
problematic for james but it was somehow safe
in the center now the queen is back on f6 but
look at white's storming on the king side so don't
be playing bishop to e7 and castling king side as
g5 will rip that whole side of the board open and
your king will be in danger absolutely he's just
tickling that b7 pawn saying you know you can't
develop your bishop anywhere um not that you have
a lot of great options but you're tied down to
defense for the moment and what he wants to do
is just slowly play like c4 bishop d3 if possible
knight you know h3 or e2 and really just slowly
get developed um i think if all that happens he
he has a very good as you said attacking position
here and e4 by james canty he's not looking to
let levy get that slow development that i was
just talking about but he missed that move i think
queen a4 check unless he intentionally did this
but queen a4 picks up that pawn without ruining
white's pawn structure so i'm going to venture and
say that james just overlooked that check which is
a nice find by levy there and i think he did yeah
bishop e7 the pawn c3 though that's under attack
so rook c1 was you know you won't repeat one i
wrote c1 it's a little slow but yeah it just
feels like this had to help levy's position
for sure um i still think you know levy's got
this strange position where he's got like four
pawns uh flying down the king's side and you know
an open file to the king in the middle it's not
like if levy castles his king is getting any
more safe so james probably has the safer king
options for the for the future but right now levy
winning that pawn back we've seen how equal or how
close this game can be when levy's down upon now
he's got it back and technically the material is
equal although i wonder what black does right now
because if you castle king side there could be g5
and that spells trouble opening the
age file doesn't seem very friendly for
black so i'm wondering if you try to even
play king d8 at some point and slide that
rook to e8 and use that to your advantage yeah
the entire queen side is pretty closed off so
even if the king just sort of hit on c7 i don't
think it would be that bad right and i guess g5 is
already a threat though for white that you have to
be careful about because black would not be able
to capture on g5 as the rook on the h8 is loose
over there so that's a tactic that i'm now better
understanding and that's something that james is
surely considering as a response to his next move
definitely and if that queen is not there
bishop d6 well in the current position at
least always hangs so something to to look
out for i wonder if knight e5 is is a move
so hang on a month let's show this
variation g5 uh h takes g h takes g
rook h1 and if gf6 knight f6 how does this play
out right because you've got this hanging knight
on g1 i guess there there's a check on a4 but that
could be interesting check on a4 and like queen c2
and queen h2 oh that's beautiful like trapping
the rook there and ending up with the advantage
that is beautiful stuff nice find there so
okay so i guess you can't go ahead and take the
the rook maybe you just have to take on g5 twice
and well you can't do that either so ooh he's
thinking about g5 for sure levy is calculating
that one out right now because it looks so strong
right you have to play queen g6 then we just
process elimination your queen is trapped
otherwise so i guess queen g6 was enough for levy
to say you know what i'm not going to force the
action there i don't see a clear conclusion
that's favorable for me let me just stop e5
yeah and i think that's the right way to go
i think the levy of five games ago might have
spent a lot of time there gone for g5 and the
game would have got wild anybody got low on time
a4 he's he's up a minute here let's keep things
controlled stop e5 he's one upon on e4 thanks to
that tactic earlier there's no need to to push the
tempo here yeah so material is even but the pawns
have been captured not the same black is a b-pawn
white has an e-pawn and many advanced pawns for
levy at this point and james yeah he's moving too
slowly i i see that he's struggling more he's even
the match score and has been playing really well
but the clock has not been his friend no no the
last couple games have been a little bit different
in those time scrambles levy has been truly
impressive in uh which is what we expect from a b5
plate that is upon sacrifice officially um if levy
wants to take that i wonder what kante is planning
um is he just gonna castle after that hey man
sometimes you got to go full toby maguire with the
pawn sacrifice but if the thing is there's rook a1
right so ab5 a takes bishop takes there's like
a rook a1 move that tries to distract the rook
so the queen on c uh can take on c3 it's a funny
move yeah queen takes c3 and everything gets hit
but there's clearly a problem with it because
the evaluation went really high in white's favor
you're perfect robert that's a great line it
looked fun it looked fun exactly these engines
taking the fun out of everything knight h3 finally
a developing move from levy we haven't seen one of
those in quite some time if you look at how many
puns he's actually moved every single pawn at
some point that he has on the board and now james
says my turn knight into e5 i wanted to play c4
and get that knight into c5 instead but perhaps
he felt enough time to accomplish that and then
on e5 it does put pressure on the f3 pawn and
after bishop takes e5 the h4 pawn is going to be
loose in many different variations yeah yeah and
you got to be careful bishop takes e5 don't take
with the pawn because there would be d6 hitting
the rook on a8 and hitting the bishop on e7 so
you would have to take back with the queen there
very good point and here knight f4 is that knight
coming just straight over there to h5 no not yet
because f3 is hanging so black does have a turn
to say knight h5 doesn't crush me just yet but it
could be a big problem in the future so he castles
wow he takes that moment to castle it's important
to note that g5 didn't quite win that pawn there
because white would throw in rook takes h8 and
draw the queen away and black castle's here so
now he's looking to probably play bishop e2
and the threat in the night knight to h5 idea
but the good news is black will have queen g6
maybe there's some kind of bishop d8 bishop a5
the reason i'm thinking about that is i want
to open the e file and i also want to improve
my really bad bishop on e7 that bishop is just
staring into its own pieces so bishop d8 comes
to mind at some point okay this is what i was
expecting from levy he guards that pawn in tens
knight to h5 and it's up to james how he wants to
react he's down getting close to about yeah 40 50
seconds and he decides to take so that long term
he always has a past apon and he does have the b
file to work with but it looks like this game is
mainly going to be decided on the king side here
it's what it seems but perhaps the b file will
come to james's advantage right if he can just
put a rook on b8 and swing it all the way down to
b2 for example i could see james countering very
quickly on the queen side if there's no immediate
breakthrough on the king's side for levy and then
suddenly the the tempo switches to the other side
of the board the time is evening out a little bit
as you see a quick reply by canty and suddenly
it seems like black has a much more obvious
plan white's position has looked good in fact it
looks almost dominating but then you're like wait
if i play knight h5 the queen will go to g6 okay
queen's safe there if i you know play g5 maybe the
queen comes into f5 or i drop a pawn so there's
thought required with every single move for levy
at this point and it feels like black can try to
make move like f to b8 or pawn to a5 as you were
talking about definitely yeah even at some point
like pawn to c4 you mentioned earlier and just
sacrifice that knight in on d3 sometimes just
opening the position we talked about how levy's
king is not the most safe uh on e1 g5 played we
do have a response that takes and queen f5 i think
is what james is going to go for and levy will
probably e4 just give up the g5 pawn and go for
the attack on the king side but perhaps that that
rook on b8 will come in handy down the line here
because at some point you can use it to attack
the queen and try to create threats of your own
yeah she decides to take it e4 to follow it's
bishop bishop i don't really want to play bishop
h7 because that gets it trapped so he goes this
way but i'm worried about the h file like can
rook on c1 land on h8 somehow that exactly that
would be a checkmate very hard to get out of f6
there's always g6 yeah but g5 is hanging for
the foreseeable future and i don't see a way
to protect it yeah not i mean bishop h4 you're
not happy to play that move and then let's not
forget about that eight pawn we mentioned earlier
30 seconds now to 14 ticking down he's got more
than double the time of levy he does this is
our final game of the five minute portion as
the match clock has expired rook b2 looks just
play that move bring that rook into the game
then bishop b5 comes to mind he takes the pump
at f4 take it wow he's going straight for it and
this has been the theme the entire match robert
he takes the pawns that levy offers but knight f6
check here oh he doesn't play it but i thought
knight f6 was a possibility there to distract
oh my goodness he's blundering this yeah left and
right unfortunately in the top two seconds and
he's just a five eight what about that a pawn yeah
let's not forget a five four three two one and he
is just trying to create threats with e6 and i
like it but it should not be taken and it isn't
by canty just now start taking the pawns yeah a3
don't mind if you do right yeah i think you can
just push push push here and even bishop b5 just
just a final move to cover and he says i don't
need it a2 rook to b1 or rotates e7 67 nicely done
he gets a queen and there's no checkmate on e8 so
nothing really to worry about there i'm trying to
invent a checkmate 2.7 seconds rookie 2 is classy
as well everything is hanging made on the board
and we are actually going to go into the break
after the five minute portion tied robert did you
expect that coming into this match at all no i
didn't and while i certainly respect james kane
iii is a fantastic player i didn't quite expect
him to be able to keep level in the longest time
patrol we've seen time and time again the stronger
player with more time in the clock tends to take
the lead but canty has come prepared he has come
emotionally pretty stable yes he was devastated
at points when he didn't win certain games but he
was able to bounce back and that final game right
there to not just you know get out of control you
blundered upon the center he said no i got this
we got this we're moving forward james cannon
the third is locked in and he's an even match with
levi rosman yeah super super impressive uh gotta
give credit to canty now levy also wiggled its way
out of some insane positions i'm just remembering
the stalemate that we saw from him and i think i
mentioned this at the beginning of the match but
i feel like the story is going to be basically how
impressive can levy be in time pressure because i
don't think he's changing anything in his style
it's just built in he's going to get low on time
he's so impressive in those time scrambles but is
he going to be able to do that enough of the time
when canty's out there just taking pawns left and
right and saying hey show me the win show me the
win it's going to be very interesting to watch
and the shorter time controls whether that time
disadvantage that levy seems to be getting into
that pressure is that going to affect the shorter
time controls more it's a question we'll have to
let the players answer and they should be looking
at their openings because it feels like they
can catch each other there especially with the
lower time limits here however we're going to
take a break i'm going to grab some water i'm on
you do your thing we will be back in just a few
minutes with more action from this levy rosman
james kane iii i'm now gm speed to
championship match brought to you by
chess.com
well of course we still have more action from this
matchup between gotham chess and jim canty but we
want to remind everybody of pogchamps 3 coming up
in mid-february presented by grip6 and other great
sponsors it's going to be another fun one with
the likes of xqc code miko ludwig and more amman
that one's going to be fun but i just can't
get this match out of my head the way that
these two players have gone back and forth
taking the lead then the match is even up
once again what to make of all of it thus far i
know it's been a wild ride there's been um leads
left right and center but there has never been uh
either player just jumping out to some crazy lead
and and leaving the other guy far behind it's
been a very close match it feels like as soon as
one of these players gets a win their opponent
comes right storming right back with uh with
win the next game so you don't get to see any
anything like a blowout some people thought maybe
you know international master versus national
master uh blowout in the five minute portion
not at all what we're seeing here is a very
close match and levy's going to need to make
some adjustments if he wants to take this match
home i think he's probably still the favorite and
after a you know tumultuous five minute portion
i don't think he's gonna be too upset being tied
but uh james canty on the other hand he's probably
feeling himself and he's reminding people that
he came to play and for those you know for the
doubters for the for the canty doubters out there
he is he's showing them why uh you know he's he's
in this tournament yeah nobody should be doubting
him anymore especially after that performance tied
three and a half three and a half among you and i
were talking before the show uh when we looked
up his stats he actually performs quite well
against title players i mean he gets ims i think
it was something like 145 wins to 170 losses
in his blitz history on chess.com so he can
score victories over these players and today he's
proving just that yeah it's a very impressive stat
line uh you know someone at the national master
level to be you know basically have a slightly
losing record against iams and even grand masters
is is insane that's that's super impressive and
i think some of the chess that he's shown today
is is a tribute to that so here we go with
uh looks like the scandy we're back to this
uh canty against rosman do you like the idea from
i guess either player to go back in this opening
i always prefer the white side of the positions
against the scandinavian john bartholomew i hope
you're watching because hashtag teamscandy we'll
see if it lasts but right now uh levy goes back
to it he did win the game with the scandinavian
it was a wild affair where both sides are chances
but right now i just like the pawns c4 and
d4 there's ease of access for white's pieces
development comes naturally i have to prefer
kenny's position well i was going to ask you and
he played it before i could get to the question
do you like his take with c5 on the position
because this is a very unique way of playing you
like this pawns on c4 and d4 but canty really
seems to want to play this position every single
time with c5 getting bishop f4 for his bishop um
getting on that diagonal hitting the c pawn and
you know it does give up that that square on d5
do you think it worked out last time like he's
repeating it as if it was uh he was happy with it
kind of feels like james gained a tempo though
because that knight was on c6 and the pawn was on
a7 for the time being so doesn't it feel like
james is just tempo head the knight d5 doesn't
work anymore because you just take on d5 and
win the c7 pawn and your d4 pawn doesn't hang
and that might be just a small small thing that
he may have checked in the break and said look
i kind of liked my position last time but why
don't i just do the same thing um up tempo now
i mean i'm gonna need some convincing here uh
robert why can't i take that bond on c7 yeah
explain that to me i was going to ask you the same
question bishop takes you i got you i got you i
asked you first like that that's a free pawn and
then just play bishop anywhere and bishop h2 was
the choice you're just up a pawn here that's
what it looks like i mean no doubt there is
going to be some pressure and you can see like
that d-pawn is going to be targeted by levy but
that's the exact same way that the previous
game worked except there was a pawn on c7
right and you made this point when that pawn was
on c7 if black moves the knight from f6 in comes
the knight to e4 and then to the d6 square so this
looks really bad for levy who's just down a pawn
and how is he going to drum up com compensation
i don't see it i get that the d4 pawn looks like
it's under attack but you really are just down
the pot yeah and the move knight like i think he's
probably gonna take this uh maybe just go knight
e5 he goes knight e4 he wants that d6 square but
basically if the queens get traded the only trick
i can see maybe happening in this position is some
sort of pin on the d file with bishop takes c5
with a loose rook there after a queen exchange
on e2 but i'm reaching i'm reaching here robert
just trying to try to find some ideas in levy's
position and i mean look at this queen on e4 the
knight can't move from d5 you drop b7 one idea for
james going for his knight e5 knight to c4 i think
okay so he plays b6 which invites pawn takes pawn
but maybe after knight takes he says all right
you have an isolated d-pawn trading off some of
the queen-side materials is beneficial but there
could be a queen b7 at the end of that yeah queen
b7 i mean let's be clear that's a pawn i think
he's got to go back to d5 but it's so candy in
this match to take all the pawns that he's offered
so he's going to do that i mean this is obvious yo
also there's knight d5 rook e5 rook takes d5
and then you win the bish 27 that's happening
look at him look at this guy go look at that boy
oh man that's very impressive he's not settling
for the pun he's incredible right now the shape
that he is in this match really is something yep
super impressive so he's got two pieces for the
rook definitely favors canty and don't forget
he's even got an extra pawn that he took a while
ago so he is he's doing very well here and levy is
gonna need a miracle to to get back in this game
and queen d3 would hope to be that miracle but
the thing was it wouldn't have worked out you're
trying to get a background checkmate white would
have thrown in queen takes e8 check first and
distracted the work from the c file so here just
rook f1 good move this knight can come into e5
the d5 pawn is hanging just move your bishop away
to give the king some space and this should be a
very easy conversion honestly for james and don't
forget about this bishop a lot of people forget
that it controls the b8 square it's just so far
away but if white you know gets attacked rook d8
he can go queen b7 hitting both pawns keeping a
watch on his b2 pawn and it can't be kicked away
on c7 or on b8 so it's very safe on b7 there
for sure so this is i don't even know 95 should
just win f7 bishop g3 queen takes f1 oh that is
that is so so nasty what he wants that's what he
wants yeah 95 closes the e file so queen f1 yeah i
just take it my king can run to e2 f7 is currently
hanging so very very good play by canty he feels
like right when he needs to be accurate he pauses
he's not playing too instinctive like bishop g3 a
lot of people might whip out that move like oh
yeah that gets my king the h2 square i'm safe
not at all no and now just move the queen
away somewhere anywhere queen d7 back because
the knight can't be captured as the rook on c8
needs that rook on e8's defense yeah okay queen
awesome great move for sure knight f7 to d6 is the
current threat um knight g6 is always on the cards
and he goes back to g8 happy with the draw is
levy in this position as you can see that eval
bar it's it's practically going for a touchdown
trying to trying to touch the eighth ring
and i think that bishop g3 is just the move that
you need here to make sure your king never gets
in any danger he doesn't queen f7 he probably
wants okay goes queen f5 and wanted a different
square for the queen and at long last he look and
say okay i can breathe now i have the two minor
pieces for the rook i also have that extra pawn my
king is safer i'm up 30 seconds everything's going
right for candy in this game and i think he might
just go king g8 back canty knees bishop g3 and and
i think levi needs to go king g8 here so there's
rook f8 watch out for it queen takes that to check
watch out for that kind of background checkmate
whoa that's so tricky from levy and i think canty
once again looks like he's taking his time if he
doesn't spot that that could be a nasty puzzle
rush win but i think he has to spot it because the
only move that would lose a queen g4 for example
so that okay he was knight of seven oh smaller
checkmate attempt that was wow that was clever
and he can take a queen trade here and i think
he probably should just for the simplicity of the
position he might look for more but that's already
enough he can play knight h6 first take the queen
at any point i don't like how he's spending
his time here though he's proven to struggle
in time travel so does knight g5 check protects
his queen and the queen trade is happening
levy trades him and the knights come to d4 and
that's a nice square for that knight bishop next
okay everything looks controlled bishop f4 to e3
or bishop e5 and f4 and he's got the setup here
levy's in trouble everything
protects everything here
it's the perfect configuration of pieces this
is seven coming knight up five can be played to
pile up oh this is just i mean you couldn't
ask for a better situation for a clinical
client it gets that move off like at the buzzer
and it's not going to help right bishop g
should be a checkmate yeah that king is running
up to h4 and it's actually going to be king h5
king g6 looks the most convincing yeah nice and
there has to be a checkmate here rookie 7 bishop
f6 he plays all right the king is going to have to
run to c8 oh rookie six and there's trade runners
rookies okay e6 bishop d8 wait um oh that works
protect on e3 that's protected i was like oh no
but okay hey moves g takes h5 he
knows what's up he knows what's up
oh my gosh james kenny up can we talk about james
candy for a second like what are we seeing here
this is an insane performance from what i think
it's fair to say a lot of people are gonna call
him the underdog on paper and i'm in that group as
well um this is really impressive by kante and did
he did he look at this as well is he changing
this from e5 i thought e5 was good for him he
says no i've looked at this maybe in the break e6
is better and he plays e6 and levy did that thing
where you pause because you don't expect the
move but you don't want to let your opponent
know that right so you you pause for a second
and then make a pretty quick response anyway
but james is the one switching it up he's the
one with the lead he's the one who's honestly
to my eyes he's kind of been playing the better
chess today so he should be confident but you
need to settle down both players need to settle
down because levy at the end of the day he's the
international master he throughout his history
has been the stronger player between the two
he of course can catch up and he's proven
especially as we get to the quicker time
patrols that in time trouble he has been the
stronger player so i think both sides they can
take their pluses thus far and not get ahead
of ourselves because there's a long match ahead
there certainly is and i think it's fair to say
correct me if i'm wrong we haven't seen a lead
in this match of more than one point so if this if
this game swings in kante's direction that could
be the first sort of sizable lead that uh that
levy is gonna have to deal with yeah and that's
tough on the emotions and we talked about this
from the top of the show is that when you are the
favorite there is pressure on you whether you want
it to be there or not like people expect you to
win you expect yourself to win you're not playing
the kind of casual comfortable chess you would
if you're just playing someone who's at your
level or even stronger than you are so i think
candy has been thriving in this environment and
right now even on the clock i do like white's
pawn structure and d6 especially that's a gonna
be a fake f6 bishop d3 the queen gets trapped
i guess there's bishop c3 check can't forget that
that move inserted but i think it's still good
for for white there yeah and bishop de that seems
smart the bishop come to a5 with check the queen
is the f6 square or the e6 square in the event of
bishop to d3 the king on e1 is kind of safe but as
this game continues i could see it getting in some
trouble yeah and i don't think that levy's upset
playing king f2 like if bishop a5 happens it might
be in his plans to play king f2 without the check
so i think he's okay with that and look at night
before that's threatening knight c2 check so you
probably have to move your king away otherwise you
play rook h2 but i don't like the look of rook h2
yeah rook c1 king f2 both look pretty reasonable
the knight if it gets kicked out eventually by a3
always has the c6 squares it's going to
reroute back to the center of the board
yeah that's the one really bad thing about playing
d6 while it just keeps that bishop on c locked in
and can't you black can't play d6 you give up the
c6 square and the diagonal because so b6 followed
by bishop b7 maybe b5 if you want to rush it but
i don't love the look of b5 as c5 also becomes
weak after that yeah b5 very committal um for
sure that's a move that we've seen from levy uh
in the other opening that we've seen a lot of
today in the the kyrokan but in this position it
looks like a bit of a reach and i think we'll see
king f2 almost immediately there it is yeah and i
wonder if james wants to play b6 but didn't like
the look of his bishop on d8 so he if he plays b6
now at least his bishop is over here on a5 quote
unquote active it's not really doing anything
definitely yep knight e2 just developing here
for levy i mean a3 is always there to kick the
knight back but he's probably saying look like i
don't really need to do that if i don't have to
g5 now that the rook is protected on h1 you can't
take that on white will play h takes g5 and even
if you throw in rook h1 um probably you can play
g takes f6 and f takes g7 which would be a crazy
line you know just as i was saying that canty was
playing the better chess today this is a great
game by levy this far it seems like he's just in
charge from the very start and this queen on f5
that's a when it's in trouble knight g3 comes
to mind let's kick that queen with a tempo
because e4 similar let's kick the queen
ooh yeah this is for where does this queen
go by the way yeah h5 i mean we've seen that
queen on h7 before but i'm not they're sure
by the way the queen is trapped regardless of if
you take that or not so king f8 oh man this is
just gruesome and that's the that's a ko as
they say yeah it's about resign time and if
you're james you probably want more games in the
longer time patrols so yep yeah that resignation
very very nice there he he basically got into a
position that i think after he played d6 don't
know if it was the best move but i like the idea
of d6 cramping the position and taking it into
uh i guess a position we've never seen before in
the match and as much fun as i make of the french
defense which is what levy is playing i think it's
a very good choice for him to not keep going into
these scandinavians or these caracons where james
has proven to get good positions so look at this
a quick castle queen side watch out for the move
d4 to d5 that can be a problem for black in many
of these positions especially their king still
in the center so this is already a fascinating
looking position but can't be seemingly
prepared based on how quickly he's played
yeah both of these guys seem to know what's
going on they eval bar right in the middle
and i mean white always has some slight
advantage here often you bring the knight back to
c3 on these lines and maybe go for a quick d5
move but i'm wondering what af because he put
the bishop on d5 like after knight c3s he almost
planned to go like c6 like i'm wondering what his
intentions are there yeah he probably would have
played c6 and said you know you'll take my bishop
we'll have opposite colored bishops but at least
my pawn structure looks better and so kenji just
says i'm going to slide my king over to b1 and
now you have to find some moves c6 was played
even though the bishop's not under attack knight
c3 is possible pretty much whenever so there's no
rush to play it but what is the plan here and what
is the plan for both sides honestly well it'd be
nice to kick the bishop out like b3 c4 uh always
comes to mind but b3 is kind of well met by b4
and you can never play c4 without dealing
with el paso there um so it's hard to kick
that bishop out hey he might need to just bring
that knight back anyway and he does so i think
levy is already kind of happy with the opening
the way this knight is just bouncing around
yeah and black is going to play knight d7 knight
b6 trying to bring that knight into the attack
so i would agree with that i think that black
is much more comfortable with the position
that you have now versus some of the other ones
you can get in this variation of the french
and if i am james i'm probably going to take this
bishop and then move my knight and i want to get
my bishop to h5 it's a common plan against
this pawn structure because the f7 square
can be a bit of a nuisance to deal with yeah
like if if black ever wants to castle queen side
suddenly bishop h5 not only can you not advance
that pawn but that pawn on f7 how do you defend
it with the pieces you have you have to stick a
rook on f8 basically leave it there the whole game
yeah and well james doing the sensible thing
bringing his pieces towards the center he's done
that all match he is slightly ahead in the clock
but about level on time thus far and well for levy
it's decision time do you play knight to b6 do you
castle queen side which is not unsafe for the king
but we did mention that f7 pawn that's one that
i would try to go after if i were james kennedy
not the not the worst thing there's also bishop
b4 um which puts pressure on the knight uh
pins it and i mean if you could take it obviously
a2 would be hanging right so he does go knight
b6 i like your idea with knight d2 i mean we
were talking about the bishop gained h5 but the
knight could also get to beat he goes knight h4
that's that has to be the wrong side of the board
i mean you see what he's looking at right
like he he sees these knight f5 tricks
and with his rook on e1 i think he was kind of
setting that up for a few moves but it does seem
like like it shouldn't work and black's attack
is actually the more dangerous one yeah bishop
b4 he played it and you have to play a3 now
because bishop takes c3 follow-up queen takes
a2 check is a deadly threat so you're getting a
bad pawn structure knight a4 at the end as well
wait knight d5 uh well i mean there's no queen
move here that attacks anything relevant i think
so that is yeah if queen c1 can you play knight
c3 check does that work probably why not n3 takes
takes a3 a3 just barely saves the day king a2 yeah
but i mean no harm no foul taking that material
but you know what's interesting about this is that
white's position does start to feel safer despite
being down the material so you give up material
you're unhappy about that levy's position for sure
is better but look at the clock situation so levy
is spending his time here whereas we're talking
about you can take a clean exchange with bishop
dixie one he's trying to figure out the tactics
and maybe he will play knight c3 check because
that was my first instinct as well i mean just
go for checkmate instead of the material yeah he
might even be looking at like bishop c3 or just
some wild moves like there's so many things to
consider here but at the end of the day look at
how much time he's spent and he has gone for it
a3 has to be on the board he only moves his top
queen to b4 check and then a3 if black plays b4
there's bishop c4 king a2 as you were mentioning
i i don't know if this is gonna get crazy and
remember he used all his time to do this so
if it doesn't work out he could be in big
trouble here but i see the evaluation bar drop
like crazy and i don't know why i know why
queen d5 checked first yeah yes queen d5 was
huge but now it's transposed back into the other
line with bishop e3 this is not clear at all
this is actually not good for black because
now actually the king on a2 is safe because
that pawnee 3 is the shield it's an umbrella pawn
and now the material is such two minor pieces for
the rook that a3 pawn will fall later in this game
not good no this is not good he's going to run
that a pawn a5 a4 that's what he wants to do but
canty is the one getting his pieces involved here
and look at the clock situation 5.6 seconds left
for levy and plenty of time for james 27 checkmate
if you take the rook so i love that move queen
a3 and he can just take on eight four no he takes
the bishop one a four yeah i was saying wow brave
move well two minor pieces better than a rook yep
knight e3 or knight g3 bishop back to
b3 bring the king back in the center
um i think canty two can take that pawn as well
don't get mated d5 yeah that's what to worry about
so d5 looks like a great move played by canty he
finds those moves when he needs to and 1.7 seconds
levy's barely getting some of these moves off but
he's really proven like he can play these bullet
scrambles yeah bishop b5 takes on d5 careful
tactics available and candy is plenty of time so
he knows he's winning he just needs to d6 now now
yeah and if rook d4 takes takes knight takes f5 d3
looks a little bit tricky still he's probably
considering what the repercussions are
should be winning for white he's got two
connected pawns the knights there as well
yep and d7 first that way the bishop can't be
captured the queen played bishop oh 95 check 95
wins in the rook yeah 95 minutes the game bishop
f3 or bishop a4 and the accuracy from kante when
he needed it there starting with queen a3 queen
c1 takes a3 and it is now five and a half to four
and a half so right after a crush from levy
rosney traps canty's queen and arguably the
the most decisive match or sorry most decisive
game of this match candy comes right back and
says oh no no you're not getting on a streak
here against me and look at this levy goes
for oh sorry james didn't play knight e4 like
he has been instead he plays queen to b6 so
james did not like that previous game he switches
the opening up but i tend to like these positions
from the white side but what james is trying to do
is just lock the board down and say i'm gonna hold
a passive worst position you have to prove that
you can win i'm ahead in the scoreboard yeah and
and i feel like we've almost seen this position
without the b2 pawn so levy's got to be happy
yeah right he gets to keep even material and
now moves like b4 are on the docket for white h5
very interesting i i'm not sure yeah and you
mentioned b4 it's out there and if b takes c5
happens i mean you gotta move the queen first of
all but after bc5 again it's like there goes the
b puns so basically white's missing the b-pod that
he's missed in every single game they played this
the black's suddenly missing a d-pod yeah this is
sort of strange to me i would say james has been
playing very well and this game doesn't quite make
sense because he didn't like what he was getting
there's something about it that was uncomfortable
he did get crushed in that previous game as levy's
best game of the match but then he goes to this
which is just pretty clearly objectively bad for
black yeah white you can see the eval bar plus
two and a half and let me tell you guys white's
not up anything material wise two and a half
evaluation that's almost like a knight or a bishop
being up at night without actually being up at
night means your position is really really good
yeah although that can mislead people to think
especially if you're newer to chess oh well
white's completely winning well prove it right
there's you're not even up a single piece it's not
actually clear how you win this game but we can
tell you one idea for white is knight d2 knight c4
put that knight on that great square where
it attacks the bishop it attacks the center
c5 is weak e5 is weak white can play pawn to f4
to explode the position with the king sitting on
f8 this is really really bad yeah i think after
knight d2 knight c4 the the nasty thing is you
follow up with a5 and then even play knight a4
after that and with the knight pressuring the d6
bishop and the knight on a4 pressing the c5 pawn
there's no b6 to stabilize and i think things just
fall apart not to mention that bishop on c8 it's
got nothing to do after black plays g5 you can
always mute it with f3 and just lock everything
down i mean look at the bishop on b8 bishop and
c8 rook on a they have not come to play this game
and black is trying desperately to play g5 g4 so i
would not have even allowed that probably i would
have put my own bishop on g5 to stop the pawn from
getting there but where's the attack it seems like
you're trying to wish an attack into existence but
you're not actually getting one no this is this
is tough after d6 i mean just look at those three
pieces robert c-88 those are the guys that come
into the basketball gym with their their duffel
bag to play pickup ball that are too shy to ask to
play or something i mean those poor guy oh knight
e8 as well there's a whole bench of them and
more coming you know it's already there are 15
people and they're switching out teams but more of
them come on bring your friends and yeah this is
this is bad i mean i'll just get that knight to h8
somehow for style points i'm willing to give you
like point two of a point if you can make that
happen you know oh gosh yeah the reinforcements
are here this is so i will point out robert i
think this is the first game just positionally
speaking where i think i'd like to point out just
the the difference in title i think this is levy
showing his item title um in a positional format
there's been so many tactical games between these
guys but start to finish from this game right here
levy is is showing some really really good chess
and it's the second game in a row with the white
pieces that levy has been able to just kind of
squish all of james's chances from the start of
the game so there's something in this trapowski
attack that james struggles with and i'm sure
we're going to get a break relatively soon and
he will need that break to study this opening
e5 falling i mean this this is just there's no
attack happening here uh up a minute let's not
forget it's not like levy is you know playing
all these moves and then he's down on time again
no he's up a minute he's crushing on the board
he certainly is and this is our final game before
we take a break it's a halfway point in this time
patrol and i think it comes at a great time
for james and for levy you're like well now i'm
feeling it like this is the chest that i've been
playing my whole life hasn't necessarily shown
throughout the earlier stages of today but this
is gotham chess at its finest absolutely king h1
just taking that extra moment i mean you want to
take this knight but their follows bishop takes h3
so just getting out of trouble and james plays
bishop takes h3 this is what we call desperation
robert there's no other way to describe it this
does not work but his position was drawing dead
so he's just throwing it out there and he's hoping
that after gtx h3 queen c8 levy forgets that his
d-pawn can move because d7 just cuts off that
queen from the attack but what you need to do
is get your queen over there so hey well now
queen c8 becomes more of a threat so keep an
eye on that d6 falls with check though so there
there's just like queen takes d6 right now it's
good queen d6 bishop c5 yeah just yep that would
have been a nice little lights out um maneuver
there it only wins the pawn but it simplifies
the game i think rook d1 is is just crushing here
yep and okay he he's now closed down any hope
for a king side attack he is up a full piece
levy rosman gotham chess is going to take this one
for sure yep there's no no doubt in my mind he's
got this game the king's on h1 it's out of danger
i mean james just doesn't have enough pieces to
uh contribute to a meaningful attack here and
f3 says yeah if you even thought about sacking
on g4 it's not happening no and you know even
if you do it i have the reinforcements i need
to work he just says no rook b6 and i
think we might see resigns here yeah
it's about that time isn't it just take on
c6 rook f6 check and then take the work on d2
rook takes c7 if you want some extra points
rook f6 if you want even more extra points
and just the rook goes bye-bye and result wow
that was a demolition that really was a one-sided
affair and levy flexed on james and i think you're
right amon that he used his wealth of experience
right he has that i am titled he has played
so much great chess he started the game very
thoroughly he just squeezed the life out of james
position yeah you you said it well there's there's
no other way to put it basically the last two
games that we've seen from levy have been crushes
and they've been with the white pieces so james
is gonna have to go into this break and really
evaluate what's been going wrong in those games
because we haven't seen that the whole match so
all of a sudden what's maybe concerning for uh
james candy the third is that when he's losing
games uh with the black pieces they're happening
really quickly and he's kind of getting crushed
so he's gonna have to go reevaluate levy on the
other hand once he stabilizes with uh the black
pieces i mean we could see a blow up match with
the way he's been playing with white for sure
if i'm james all i'm doing in this short break
is looking at the black side of this trompowski
attack just trying to figure out a line that
makes me feel more confident because right now
it is not working out but with mom and i
are going to take a break we will return
shortly with more coverage of this gotham
cantee i'm not gm speeches championship match
and as we return getting ready for more three
minute plus one second increment time patrol
games we have to enjoy that the match is tied up
five and a half five and a half for those of you
who root for the underdogs james canyon iii came
to play and amman what do you think going forward
here after james just suffered a pretty brutal
defeat to levy rosman i think that uh james is
probably happy to have that break the last two
games that he had the black pieces in uh let's say
bluntly he got crushed and we haven't seen that
in this match so far so i think he's really happy
that he gets to take time to regroup check those
games over maybe and say look what went wrong in
those games that wasn't happening the rest of the
match so i think he wanted that break and levy
probably a little bit upset he you know he was
just starting to find his rhythm and his momentum
he just got a crushing win and all of a sudden the
guys are on break so we're going to come back from
this break and we'll have to see how it affects
the players but i think that kante was was happy
to just you know revamp after that last game yeah
you know he gets to look over his openings both
with the black color where he's struggling against
the trowsky attack and then with the white pieces
he now needs to figure out is levine continue
playing the french is he going to go back to that
cairo khan and we'll get the pan off again will
he go for the scandinavian which we saw a couple
of times and for levy you know he can say hey i've
been playing better chess as the match has gone on
that should bode well for my chances in the bullet
and well we have the answer scandinavian it is
yep and once again knight f6 and we're gonna
see this line repeated i don't think that
i mean levy's gotten some results in this line
but i don't think canty can be too upset i mean
he played a crushing game last time but levy
has probably also looked at that move order
yeah and well we see that e6 now james is thinking
he's down 10 seconds why we ever seen him spend
so much time and he's had this position before
so i wonder what's happening that caused him a
moment of pause there and levy goes bishop before
and i think that what um what's been happening
is that kante is like he's playing this position
again and he's kind of pausing because he's like
wait a minute why is levy why does he want to
go for this again these have been good positions
for me and he's maybe just pausing and thinking
should i change things up because maybe he looked
at this in the break in the end he goes for c4
and bishop b4 check is kind of the new idea by
levy instead of bishop d6 and he takes which gives
white these double pawns but the semi open b file
to work with only white has a dark square bishop
which can be used on f4 or g5 later in the game
and one of the big questions as always do you
just castle and give up the c3 pawn i would i
i would say yes yeah i wouldn't spend much time on
it i would castle canty has done that i personally
don't think levy is going to take that pawn um
but we'll see he could have a different strategy
coming in uh he castles it's just too risky you
take on c3 you do win a pawn for the time being
but white his moves like bishop b2 and pawn d5 and
the board opens up it was black's king that would
be in danger so instead he simply castles rook to
b1 is a good move and that rook can slide up to b5
and then swing to the king's side which is
probably why levy protected b7 with the queen
yep yeah if you play b6 then basically you
give this exact same move but with a tempo
right and well where is levine developed at night
i would want at first glance i would have wanted
to play knight b to d7 knight to b6 but with that
rook on b5 like well what am i really gaining
from this maneuver yeah and a knight on b6 i mean
even if you play queen a4 to somehow attack that
pawn there's always c5 and that that pawn of b7
ends up hanging so canty already off to i would
say a good start he's got this rook b5 idea
and careful on that king side because there
could be a lot of firepower knight e5 to g4 and
as you mentioned robert that rook swinging over
could be the theme of this game yeah that's it's a
dangerous position but h6 play just ain't no rook
to g5 no bishop to g5 you would like to put your
pawn on g5 if you're white but g4 seems to hang a
pawn on the square there so i don't think you can
get away with it but you it gives you a hook is my
essential point right um lots of moves for white
here rookie one bishop f4 even nike five they all
look very reasonable uh h6 i think is important
to stop that rook from swinging over to g5 but
one of the reasons that white's attack could be
so successful in this game is that queen on a6
so far away from the king it can't really get over
to help with defense um as james is thinking a lot
here robert actually what you just said inspired
me g4 it is you take me on g4 i'll play h3 king h2
or h1 rook g1 and maybe instead of h3 just king
h1 and rook g1 and just go for the attack whoa
talking about going for the attack here like
what's the follow-up is he playing queen
e5 to g3 with some knight sacrifice like what's on
the cards here queen e3 and after king there is it
gonna be knight g5 takes rook takes with me oh
my goodness that seems to be what he's going for
and if if you start with king g7 maybe there's g5
check where you give up your rook and then your
queen slithers in there and wins the knight on f6
and that king is in real danger on the hill yep
and and keep in mind that the initial sacrifice
the computer is probably like whoa whoa whoa
whoa and now it's creeping back to equal when you
sacrifice a piece and you're attacking the king
and it's equal you've done something right a
hundred percent and king g7 was in fact played
moves like 95 are tempting as in addition to
that rook g5 check rook g5 king h7 where's the
where's the crushing factor because if you don't
find something concrete you have given up a piece
for just one pawn yep absolutely brook g5 takes
takes king h8 take on f6 at least a draw there
yeah and if king h7 okay he goes for this and i
think this is absolutely correct what an attack
so far 34 seconds he just he just punches
it in there's plus one second increment but
if if levy gets low on time here defending a
crazy attack like this is not what you want
to be doing not at all and actually maybe after
king h7 you just play rook g3 with the idea being
you're gonna play rook h3 next and there really
is an attack here knight e5 comes to mind queen
d3 check you have so many different options
and playing against this attack it's too scary
especially in a blitz game absolutely agree i feel
like the eval bar is like yeah it's a draw guys go
figure it out i'm taking the day off you know like
i can't i've done enough swinging in this match
like there's no way i can calculate all this no
and that's the thing about this is this happens to
grandmasters plenty right there are openings
played and then someone makes a sacrifice
because you didn't leave your engine going
for long enough it doesn't see that deeply
and that sacrifice works out even though
you thought it wouldn't so i think here
rook g3 to start makes sense and one important
point to note is if black plays rook g and takes
on g3 white will take with the f pawn to
open up the f-file another avenue of attack
yeah brook g3 and like knight e5 queen e5
he wants to take on f6 but hello knight d7
i think he forgot that he's gonna go queen g3
and try to take but now it's not working for sure
no he forgot knight d7 and this
is this could be a win for levy
a big defense and we'll see because the king is
still really unsafe he plays rookie that is a
smart move he doesn't think of the tactics two
pawns for the piece but that's not enough here
no queen c6 threatening queen f3 has to be
queen f4 and queen takes c4 g4 also looks good
and levy down to 7.8 seconds but at some point i
should say james near the same so this anything
can happen in the time scramble but levy is just
up material he's up material yeah h3 by white
is probably a move you want to throw in just
necessary for sure check that time levy's time is
taken down h4 threatens h5 oh i don't really like
h5 for black because that pawn's on a loose square
but still black of course is doing very well
here queen f3 hits f7 as well yeah and take on f7
uh-oh we just take rook g7 and t1
is hanging wow that's crazy okay
queen of three and it's a draw of queen g4 so
he plays rookie one oh but getting the king
to g7 is huge for levy it might not look like
much but that knight is going to sneak in f4
and the time is incredible here three oh
rook g3 was hanging with the queen on b6
king h2 i like that move for white queen f3
hitting the pawn yep and the wrestling e4 queen
takes h5 that's a big pawn to lose because
now it's overwhelming okay takes queen f3
oh f2 is hanging and then queen f5 oh he
must slip maybe no but he's gonna take it
now i guess it didn't matter he is a piece that
95 too powerful oh my goodness if i'm james i'm
resigning i want more three you look like a mouse
yeah i kind of did right stop one move short one
square short i said queen takes b7 uh yeah hang on
this is i would play this out check it don't check
nicely done yeah nice done queen f2 is the threat
queen would have won here goodness check
again queen d5 check would have traded queens
oh okay blender the queen yeah he just laughed
about it kind of he's like it's too much to ask
wow that felt like a bullet game
because we spent so much time
at the like three seconds of peace uh portion
that was insane that was extremely wild and
james goes for bishop takes h6 which was
completely unnecessary but still dazzling
and i don't know if it was truly justified
but he went with it and he paid the price
levy looks like he's playing this game like his
hand is playing this game but his brain is still
in the last game he he's just like you know what
the hell just happened there well his position
is bad with white on move seven right knight d5
was played if the bishop goes this way knight e3
comes to mind or just taking e5 first and yeah
this feels like there's too many loose squares
in white's position to be truly comfortable
let's take it by e6 that's what he's gonna do
this is bad this is bad i like
knight e3 i would take that bishop
that was my first instinct but then i was like
wait maybe i'll just feel a calmer he says no yeah
no i i think that e6 is the better move maybe
but i just can't refuse i just can't remember
this knight takes g3 there's no mate i teach you
three levy throwing in that in between move but
hang on he's just thinking about it now and he
knows that he missed that oh yeah his face his
reaction there was like what am i doing he wanted
the brilliancy prize i'm just gonna show quickly
what levy wanted you know queen g6 checkmate hello
but um doesn't work like that knight takes g3 and
he's down was it two pieces robert yeah he could
take on d7 but that just gets one piece back and
trades queens and the black king is safe so
what's interesting about that moment right there
is i didn't really like white's position anyway
but it felt like what james had done in the
previous game kind of like an unnecessary tactical
idea and it backfired more immediately for levy
than it did for james but still that was clearly
an oversight don't play knight e5 or knight
c5 here or proper i guess e5 is okay yeah knight
c5 takes on f7 and you lose your queen right so he
plays knight h5 bringing the knight back into the
game he's up two pieces right now yeah it's just
crazy you have to take on d7 unfortunately it's
just you must do that what about queen d5 here
queen d5 yeah that's a funny one queen defy i like
it i like queen d5 i think windy five you had to
play knight e5 and sacrifice your night that way
and you're you're winning but and then just knight
f6 after it forced you to at least find a single
move there just play e6 james takes king back or
g6 all fine the knight's gonna come to f6 so a
full full extra what is it peace for canty he's
got the two bishops as well there's a rook on h3
everything's wrong here for levy but you know that
that doesn't need reiterating it's just can james
canty the third put this game away and tie this
match up again well i think levy's doing the right
thing by playing on first of all there's a king
on f7 that could become a problem later it's not
going to but also levy has been the better player
in time for this is devastating queen b2 queen
g1 yeah that's it yeah that's because queen c3
like hitting the rook and hitting that not only
is there bishop b4 winning the queen but there's
bishop g7 this queen takes check on g1 that's
just nothing works here yeah yeah he digs b2
he's gonna play on though because he wants to get
to the bullet portion without seeing his uh his
match score go down right he's if you lose this
game or when he loses this game because he yeah
he will still be tied in the match and he is the
favorite in the bullet so i think it's smart in
terms of match strategy to play on here yeah this
is this is as over as a as a game gets really um
james is up on time the evaluation is like -14 i
don't know this is like this is like some sort of
cleveland brown spread or something what are
we watching here hey the browns just won up the
playoff game so don't hate on them too much no i
was uh i was cheering for them against the stars
yeah they uh that would that well that wasn't
even a game right the first quarter was 28
nothing that was ridiculous but this position
is kind of like that actually yeah after seven
moves or whatever it was james was up a piece
so yeah this is no good is that queen on a1
not helping queen h7 check is a threat rook takes
d7 comes to mind so you need to be a little bit
careful if you're james and probably knight
to f6 just says none of any of that for you
yeah i'm trying to find a check
but h7 is covered g6 is covered
ugh yeah queen is going to go to c1 now yeah
that queen on v2 is like you know that the
kid and capture the flag who's hiding out in
your territory for the whole round you sort
of forget about him sure then it's uh the right
moment just pounces and takes the yeah he just
pops off and grabs the flag and starts running
it's the hero that you need but not the one you
deserve so there's 95 check and there's queen h7
check we got checks threatened oh 95 okay king f8
king e8 also there's no checks after that
yeah e8 queen h7 there's queen e5 yeah
but it does look like levi's made progress and
he's also up on time and we've seen james blunder
in time trouble yeah yeah like let's talk
about the fact that the pieces that james is
up he hasn't moved yet right they are on the
queen side so it's like it's a matter of time
before that happens and what is he setting up
here some sort of like knight g6 or queen h7 move
she's got some hopes okay you can't play b6 next
because you're working aids hanging so it's like
frustrating because you're of course
winning with the black pieces here but
you you need to make moves like rook to b8
and james play the move quickly so that's
a good move to play and the time deficit is
about to be nothing okay e8 safe move yeah
e6 is covered he's just gonna go back he wants
queen h7 now that's the idea but canty is not
having any of that knight g4 bishop g7 everything
looks covered wow queen g6 check king f8 it's just
amazing bishop g7 h6 wait bishop do you have a
queen g6 jack and if queen f7 is rook d8 right
yep and there's knight h6 oh god knight takes
h6 wait this is actually a bit scary is a queen
g6 check you have the king east all right can't
f8 maybe yeah i think queen g6 check i mean we
need to see that on the board whoa c4 that can't
be it but it it at least cause confusion because
e6 may loosen the c6 square or b5 was played but
maybe there's a check on c6 at some point that you
have to watch out for is a queen h7 queen f7 now
because rook f8 okay can't he still hasn't really
established the rest of his pieces in this game
and i think he's about to yeah he got it bishop
d7 is huge now the knight on g4 is covered by the
bishop on g7 canty is i think he's fine though and
bishop d4 check should be sufficient okay where's
the mate there should be five wins there it is
oh and that's that and i mean honestly like i'm
pretty impressed that that levy took the game that
far that was that was really impressive but let's
not forget that that game was actually just candy
uh taking advantage of levy's blunder of a full
piece in the opening going for a fancy movie e6
yep and so the match is now tied and now we have
a french again and it's not your everyday french
where black has double pawns and white didn't have
to give up the dark square bishop to encourage
blacks to get those double wait a second queen
f3 is coming if you play bishop v7 so be careful
yeah i guess you can survive with like queen
d7 because the knight is nowhere near but f6
is hanging in those lines oh yeah f6 is
hanging so yeah that's true this is weird
and d7 is just not the move you want to do
by the way even after bishop d7 queen f3
knight e7 like bishop takes d7 you have to take
with the king f6 is hanging that's not even clear
no so queen d5 played and that protects the knight
attacks the bishop and attacks the g2 pawn so c4
will be met by queen take g2 but
then def oh my goodness this has to
that would be wild c4 queen takes g2 d5 and
then queen takes h1 bishop takes c6 check
too much to calculate yeah i'll let them do
it it looks to my eyes especially if this
were a bullet game i would be playing that
so quickly but considering it's still blitz
for james you have so many options you can play
bishop back to e2 and then put the bishop on f3
i like that i think that is the best move and i
wouldn't be surprised to see that by kante after
some calculation here um we just don't want to see
these players throwing away the game early on like
c4d5 could just be losing and we've seen a number
of games so far just thrown away in the opening
too much time being spent though
like you just need to move
yeah he should be e2 i think he's going to play
c4 and d5 based on oh he plays queen b3 i was
like based on the amount of time he's spending
he wants to castle what what no he doesn't what
does he want to do here he's going to play d5 and
then castle and take on c6 and all that good stuff
yeah yeah d5 castle wow so queen takes g2 d5 first
or orc castle looks like d5 first yeah d5 first
queen takes h1 and then maybe just castle
there or bishop c6 first all looks good
yeah pretty wild position and i saw levy's face
he was like first shot then he's like oh and then
now he's like okay now that i've gone through
my visceral reactions let me actually calculate
and maybe quitting g2 looks almost forced to me
yeah queen takes b3 keep in mind bishop takes c6
check intermezzo you cannot get
away with just like saying oh okay
this looks wild i don't want wild let's
trade the queens that's not an option
yeah and if you move the queen back and say well
why'd you allow the queen to come to b3 and if
you play bishop d7 i'll just trade queens and
you're stuck with this really ugly pawn structure
the double f pawns that are isolated the d-pawn so
this seems like you might have to take on g2 and
levy appropriately spending his time figuring out
is that just losing and if not hey that's the move
i'm going to go for and both players basically
spend about a minute or 45 seconds a piece
looking at uh queen b3 for james canty iii and and
queen takes g2 for levy and bishop d7 now this is
the thing is we we both were like oh we'll let
the players figure it out because it is a really
complicated position but now it's not complicated
and it's not complicated in very favorable ways
for james because look at the pawn structure
yeah and i think levy has just sort of realized
or he's willing to admit that hey these tactical
struggles with james they aren't necessary like
why don't i just take a position where the queens
are off and i can try to just outplay him uh
on the board um because those tactical games are
not always working out for him no they are not
and even this position with the bad pawn structure
it's not that bad for black it's kind of playable
yeah yeah for sure you uh can trade off some
pieces your rooks will just try to go to e8 maybe
won't go to g8 it's obviously better for white
but it's not so clear-cut and now f5 all right
king d2 i think and bring the king to d3
even just yeah yep that definitely looks good
um even bishop f4 if you want to go for
for that trade is perfectly fine here
and important to note there's no rook g8 because
knight f6 check will fork the king and rook so
okay g3 it's one of these positions of mine
where you know that f4 for black is an idea
but you're never sure if you actually should play
it absolutely i was thinking the exact same thing
it's like you play it and then usually as soon
as you do you regret it and you're like why did
i just give up a pawn for nothing basically you're
shattering white's pawn sure but down in the palm
but you're also giving white the g file which is
not ideal so he does move his king to c6 i like
that move actually and now what yeah he wants
to play rookie 8 but knight f6 was simply gonna
win the exchange there rookie
eight there's not a knight g7 so
that's hilarious yeah gotta watch it for all
that oh knight g7 you called it you called it
and it's an ups oh he didn't see it wow that's
a big miss because that was a free pump yep
um it's weird i don't mind the move f4 i really
like the idea of fixing that pawn as a weakness on
f5 so now there is no f4 that we've been talking
about but as you mentioned it's just only a bad
move because knight g7 was missed now if you go
knight g7 he's probably seen it by now but there's
knight e7 to cover right and so can you take on
h7 or is f6 trapping the knight no you move your
bishop out the way fish from anywhere bishop oh
actually f2 but then takes and bishop e7 yeah
there's also just king d7 so g oh nice move though
rook takes e3 brook takes e3 takes bishop takes f4
and then rookie one and you have king d2 and the
f6 pawn is hanging so your knight gets out like
what in the world yeah i think he needed to start
with the rook there i think that was important
yeah because this exact nice move rook h8 takes
nh2 with check great king d3 and after bishop e3
okay king f3 now and then you've rookie one
rookie six check well what you give the f4 pawn
he simply forgot that king g3 or king g5 hits the
knight you don't win a knight or anything there
yeah he was shaking his head and now that g-pawn
is gonna try to roll up the board nine second this
is literally a time scramble and chances for
both sides the e valve are right in the middle
just a pin drop okay knight h4 check king g5
then i go back to f3 maybe we'll get a draw in
this way or the king actually go up the board
maybe oh he takes the pawn levy wants more and
he can even stack the ball rook g2 okay this
is good for black only move is rook f1 now
king somewhere you get five okay so g6 is
coming this is scary yeah oh he's gonna
stack and take on c3 i think and i like
the idea what's this 96 is his plan but c5
take it well black wins this yes yes wait now
black's definitely going to win yep it's winning
for sure i think james really struggles in time
trouble 1994 oh my goodness but 94 was winning
the c pi might have still been winning for black
but yeah needed to be played yeah now this is over
to win for eleven uh yeah i think this
is a sign of things to come if you ask me
just the scrambles pretty much every
single one that's been a 50 50 has gone
his way yeah and that means that we are going to
be heading into the break as you see levy get up
from his chair there he is you know emphatic to
to take the lead at the end of the portion which
means we're going to the bullet one game lead
for international master levy rosman and i mean
what what do you reflect on in that three-minute
portion if you're james canty you know what you
have to do it's just comes down to one word move
because he's really been deliberating and that's
great he's trying to play the best possible chess
but even in great positions he then leaves himself
with not enough time and he doesn't feel confident
in the scramble so i think what james needs to do
is just play these openings and he's getting
pretty decent positions out of and just go you
are not unless you blunder in the first 10 moves
you're not going to lose in that period of time
and you need the remaining time to be able to win
when the position gets complicated yeah this is
going to be a very exciting conclusion and just as
a fan and a commentator here in the booth with you
robert i am so happy that that this match has done
more than live up to expectations because this is
a very tight match one game separates these guys
and unless someone gets completely blown out in
the bullet portion here this is gonna be a very
exciting finish it certainly will and the bullet
remains but for now we're gonna take a quick
break and when we return we will have the final
time patrol and the remainder of this i'm not a
gm species championship match brought to you by
chess.com
just want to remind all of our viewers and
streamers out there that arena king season 6
is underway it started on monday there will be
another event just two days from now on friday
get involved have some fun and play against some
of your favorite personalities it will be a great
time speaking of great time we're having a blast
here as gotham chess takes on gm canty it is a
lead for gotham levy brosnan up seven half six and
a half ahmad united were just talking during the
break it is a lead for levy he's the high rate the
two bullet players would you say that james has a
chance or has it gone by at this point i think it
would be um uh insulting at this point to not say
that james has a chance he uh was the underdog
in blitz the same way that he's going to be the
underdog in bullet but i think he has come to play
on match day he's been playing some great chess
and whenever he's lost the game he's bounced
back with a win so of course levy could come out
of the gate in this bullet portion blazing and
just really take it to him and show why he's a
high rated player but what we've seen in this
match so far is james can absolutely compete
so don't count him out of this bullet portion he's
only down a single game robert absolutely and you
and i during the break we were looking up the
history and against teddy coleman levy actually
lost the bullet portion of that match despite
being much higher rated so here we are what
what nice disrespect he says get that trump asking
the hell out of here and did you see levy laugh
he's just like what is this there's no way that
was on purpose was it that james didn't even he
didn't even blink he was like yep knight g8 yep
now that is a power move just knight back to g8
and looked at that one in the break what just do
you think that was a mouse slip of sorts what what
just happened i i but what most slope i i don't
know but nobody voluntarily goes knight back to g8
that's wild if he wins his first game
off that that is just a power statement
i mean he's james has a terrible position he's
down a couple tempe and his position is bad knight
f5 comes in yeah e6 was needed there oh bishop
f8 we have the second piece returning home robert
oh that's a sad move to play but maybe
it's not as terrible as you think e6 okay
to h5 like oh that's yeah that's pretty
painful because black needs to play like
knight b6 bishop b7 queen e7 and castle long you
definitely an a6 you don't have time to play this
bishop h5 is coming yeah this is this is gonna
hurt oh bishop h5 rook h7 holding on for dear
life needs to be needs to be and it is queen f2
something like that maybe rook f2 and rook f1 this
looks very painful yeah even something slow as
you said rook f2 rook takes f7 he's got he's
got nothing to worry about an e5 he wants yeah
he's fine but trey queens yeah it's reasonable
okay there's some chance here it's still great
for white of course when we see the evaluation
board say as much but bishop e ah bishop
b7 takes and then bishop d6 or something
okay so bishop d7 i think you have to play and
after ef6 for bishop of a yes wow nicely played
by canty he's pretty much equalized the position
here and he's up on time what in the world has
happened in this game rook v8 that b file has
come in so handy to james throughout this match
yes absolutely bishop c6 that looks like the move
there's also h5h4 ideas if you're not careful to
try to a5 a4 as well a5a4a3 that's actually a
really good plan here goes h5 yep uh wait takes
and takes g2 you take f6 okay take f6 is better
king seven wait that knight is kind of trapped
over there isn't it now no knight f4 bishop
check oh well ruby two's happening so d6 though
that is so tough can you
go bishop e5 knows king f6
back h5 check dude bring that key to
e7 you have to what oh my g6 97 oh
yes oh my goodness what is happening here so you
can't really trade rooks no he's going to go back
to rook check brook d2 nice keep the rooks on
you have to rookie one you just have to move you
to play for levi's time trouble here his own time
trouble yeah that's the problem oh my goodness he
needs a move he needs to move e4 is a good one
rook g7 check e3 resolve it just resign resign
i'm telling you okay just don't let me use things
i don't know i would play this but it's probably
a bad idea well the thing is i'm trying to save
massive but you're right there's only one pawn
remaining so if you lose that pawn then the game
is suddenly a draw it's not insane no rook you
won rookie one putting the rope behind the pawn
was good yep oh he can't just keep checking you
now i would have designed it yeah knight f2
check happening and our king f2 king even
yeah now absolutely resigned for the match but
i i sort of get why he's playing on basically
he sees that one point just get that pawn
off the board you know it will be a draw
i would have resigned so long ago
it's wasting the best strategy
yeah and yeah oh we both the same
exact reaction just a small oh
honestly though canty after playing knight
g8 which we're going to have to ask him
oh gosh and he plays this version of the
french the monte carlo variation and this is
interesting because you get an isolated pawn
but you get really good activity around it
but i was gonna say hang on a bullet you take on
h3 every time so this is like how magnus lost to
bujong zee this like famous attacking game where
he just stacked and it's like what are you gonna
do about it wait so does this work isn't white go
like queen f3 now and just okay queen so queen of
three knight there queen g3 doesn't work i mean
h3 queen h3 looks playable okay he played queen g2
wow this is wild knight f3 check is a devastating
threat this queen is your mate will follow so
you probably have to i think you gotta grab it
take it and then you should have worked just give
up uh give up the rook or the exchange rather
oh wow okay it covers the f3 square wow that's it
covers e2 that is a tough move to play when you
don't have much time so if c6 okay if we move that
to f5 so never mind very reasonable position yeah
i like that as well just get the bishop out of
the way wow this is a wild game and james down
a lot of clock yeah james is laser focused
right now and his life is just sipping water
he's more used to playing these bullet scrambles
so that's going to come in handy it has been
the better player between the two in the bullet so
far and okay bishop f3 he's trying to get rid of
the attackers but just take on e3 a bunch of times
f4 hangs there's also bishop c5 um to pin the uh
the e3 okay this doesn't look as bad as it once
did yeah the knights going back like that i mean
it's all about time at this point i think james
has done a fantastic job defending him yeah he
really has he's all these pieces towards his king
although f5 is a great move bishop c2 in knight g4
the knight comes in g3 i guess you have to yeah
okay nitrogen so knight e3 pawn takes knight g4
and then e knight moves out the way this is such a
wild position my goodness it's too cluttered so he
fixes something i agree with this decision even
just like g6 or like knight g4 bishop c5 those
type of moves yeah and i think that no matter what
james is going to bring his knight to either d or
f4 three seconds a piece yep f5 is going to be
hanging sometimes bishop 396 kind of stuff yep
he plays e4 that's oh that is a risky move can't
really get behind that three minimum 93 all right
that makes sense we're 64. now this is opening up
for both sides and actually oh no we needed rookie
for it yeah rookie four looked better to trade off
some pieces no eve one's hanging oh it's hanging
yeah this is the scheme but but it is clear
if he had played brooke takes e4 there
robert that absolutely could have led to even
the checkmate for white yeah i mean i'm still
trying to wrap my head around all those tactics
and that's what happens to us chess players right
we see this and we're like wait what just happened
let me let me remember was there does that work
and the next game is fully underway so queen takes
b2 here by kante you're down three points on the
scoreboard you just have to take the pawn and hope
that you tell the tale yeah and let's be clear
in bullet all the games that we've seen so far
are gonna work out just that little bit better for
levy just because of the fact that the time is
lower and it's even going to castle i think he's
going king f1 and knight t5 ideas yeah because
you try to open up the h file so that rook
is dominating an attack i think this is a crut
i think this might be a crush for levy bishop
c3 g3 knight g5 yeah i did like to move bishop
f4 because at least it creates some threats and
caused some confusion but you're right bishop c3
just to get out of it don't trade pieces the queen
has to go but where does it go too ooh queen e7
rookie 2 to e2 with tempo yeah rook b1 players
okay this suddenly isn't as bad as i thought it
was going to be this should be five you have to
and black has an extra pawn but white has the
bishop pair and what could be a nasty attack yeah
i still think king king g2 rookie one f4 is it's
gonna be like really rough here yeah but yeah you
gotta you gotta take this a scan to take that bond
and play this game out that's how you gotta try it
so he plays knight f6 but he just gives up
the pawn in the center and now he doesn't even
extra material for his troubles right so he's
gonna have to rely on some kind of b5 at some
point maybe take a bishop g4 or just bishop g4
initially i think taking is maybe a bit better but
the level is the same yeah levy just in time your
king g2 because that bishop could sit on f3 that'd
be a problem for white's coordination but he
got his communications almost trapped by the way
yeah it's a close call takes takes f3 there is
e3 as a resource and not only does it save the
day it actually just turns black's position
into a promising one so a good move knight
d7 levy sitting and thinking he is down right
back to e1 tough move to play but i like it yeah
tough move to play i agree he does it wow great
move yeah that's that's a classy move there f3
intended next with g4 h5 he's gonna whip that out
i think although the problem is that c4 pawn on
light square the knight and bishop can team up
so if somehow this bishop gets some open space
from d7 it can apply pressure knight a4 happens
a6 b5 likely a follow-up and you called it
that's gonna be on the board and these two bishops
i mean they're gonna be dangerous in the end game
but they're more dangerous with the queen on the
board and how about three seconds for levy yeah
he's had no time so many different games in this
match and here just take on e4 play rook on d8
rook d8 it looks good yep you think he's deep if
you don't play rook d and d7 rookie eight is kill
it with bishop g7 check so f6 here and if before
g5 you kick the bishop away you win the d6 pawn
this is huge look at that time as well yeah and
then 94 seconds and the 984 is a hero protecting
that c5 pawn oh but here comes here comes levy and
slowing down is james canty we've seen this before
we have and he put the knight in the wrong square
knight b2 without the knights go to d3 with check
to fork the bishop if it captured on c5 so still
is this okay for canty base at least got to draw
here although he might win this yeah he's got to
put pawns on light squad 35 oh he didn't do it and
i was waiting his nice trap he's gonna lose oh
my gosh he's gonna lose wow he's lost this game
oh that is devastating that might be everything
right there and he knows he's shaking his head
wow yeah that's that wow wow that's one of those
games where you can't fathom how you lost you were
up a pawn in an end game where there were like six
pieces on the board and yet his knight got trapped
and the g3 pawn would have been protected so a win
for levy rosman and he's just running away with
this match he's gotta basically james has to start
winning right now he he has to start winning um
because the time he's gonna decide this match
that the match time 13 minutes and ticking down
yeah and i i mean i like what he's doing here
you need to win you need to win quickly let me
sacrifice one pawn sacrifice a second break open
the position and if you take on f5 bishop g2 the d
whoa okay i guess the uh d4 pawn was pinned
there so it works out wow and getting e4 is
huge if white could somehow break with c4 that
would [ __ ] shatter the entire pawn structure
and shake up things entirely but look at
these pawns h5 t4 d5 e4 so frustrating
yeah the bishop's just locked in there on g2 and
you somehow can't uh get the base pawn the d5 pawn
can't be taken okay nicely done so some kind
of knight c5 makes sense to me but lavi should
ignore it it's like knight g5 just to try to open
up the d file and get to the d5 pawn but exactly
closing the position down i think the knight is
trying to go to e3 but a bishop on f4 will make
that's so hard to do and yeah he's trying to get
c4 but b4 says it's amazing how levy's piece is
just completely dominating here bishop f4 to g5
knight f6 bishop so don't fall for that bishop e4
right so okay he stopped it and this
remember yeah king d6 also worked
no just take on e3 take that was good
enough king d6 is a great move as well
uh levy is kind of in cruise control at the
moment he's stopping to hydrate a little bit
yeah now uh the match is completely out of control
for james canty and well i think if you're levy
you look at the score it's about to be five
point lead only 11 minutes left and you're the
one dominating the bullet portion you must be
thrilled considering how this match looks just
five games ago exactly it's a great great
point i mean white's kind of pretending to
hold on here but the position is actually so so
lost um like rook c8 i think he's probably good
enough yeah i can't protect your c2 pawn
rook g3 can happen any moment as well but
this is solid rook g3 rook g3 bishop d2 bishop c3
check white can't move completely frozen bishop e3
i'm just he's finding everything now every move
just that takes the life out of james's pieces
like knight g4 is simple enough yeah i'm just
gonna go for that indeed in the nice trap still oh
h3 is even playable bishop d2 to c3 and
h3 i think h3 rook g1 just wins the night
that's you're right oh wait that was a little
blunder there it looks a little blunder yeah
he's got three seconds but you gotta move he's
gotta move that's for sure wow he keeps doing that
and rookie three did james
somehow survive this king c1
that was a big blunder a series of blenders wow
c3 get a pass spot yep c4 same idea and this
should be a draw with best play but when you're
playing bullet there is no best play it's just no
not at all king is coming to f5 and e4 this is
scary wow whose pawn is going to be better you
give up the d-pawn but you push up on the b6 king
c5 i like when you did that f3 rook before check
so you have to watch out for that and here b6
take a take on d5 even d6 yeah you can take on
default works wait but who's if you can't allow
that queen if you allow that queen you're going
to check oh now he's got a rook f5 he's covering
him he's going to at least get a draw here
and king c7 and that's a draw wow wow so
a huge covenant that game was over robert
that's what happens as commentators when
you call a game before it actually concludes
the other results happen and yeah here we have
another wild position with knight to d5 he's
giving up a knight because the bishop on the d5
is saying it's just crazy takes knight back to c6
f4 this looks like a position that probably both
players wanted from the opening honestly bishop d3
kind of looks like black should be
pretty happy right now unless you can
get your knight to d4 and bishop to e3 but i
always have queen b6 and your bishop is stuck
oh that looks like a good move takes back and then
play b4 again now oh now he gets it with bishop e3
though this could be concerning although f6 right
standard french type of have to play f6 and he
does he does yeah and then center's collapsing and
the white kings in the center take on e5 steal a
pawn don't mind if you do right absolutely bishop
d7 i mean there were pawns for the taking there
and some kind of queen h4 comes to mind
knight takes e5 still it was finally yeah
you guys shook my e3 he could take
it anyway and long last it's gone
okay so he's just playing rookie one maybe king
h1 bishop f4 or something like that from levy
although trading off pieces has knight takes
e6 and bishop takes e6 maybe an option i don't
know no but it's bishop e6 and bishop takes h3
so you just keep the exchanges happening there
yeah yeah there might have been like a bishop c5
at the end of that one but just wild stuff yeah
too much to calculate it's bullet it's bullet guys
yeah just take with the pawn everything take dc7
right and e5 falls but then it's queen b8 if
you take eight and maybe you should make the
the diamond structure play b5 yeah b5 for sure oh
uh on that's hanging oh that is bad protected past
a pawn here that might be it that might be the
game right there if that pawn can get to a5 okay
so that's actually c8 doesn't work uh he takes a
three queen c3 rookie six because you just have
to trade off things but yep this is just good for
life levi in these critical moments he just finds
a way to like slip away from pressure and then
find the counter shots when they're available to
him clutch yeah yeah has been and let's see here
you take on c6 rook takes and the rook's going to
try to go to g6 so it puts his rook on d1 which
makes sense looks like a good move james is just
down to the final seconds the problem is he can't
trade i like queen a7 but there's just nothing you
can offer after we're d5 here well you traded and
take on a4 and you rook d5 or b8 rookie one check
that was nasty nice fine there and queen takes and
yeah canteen doesn't have any hope here because
the back rank's covered and levy can
just close his eyes and push those pawns
yeah now it's easy one second taking down like at
this point is just too clinical for levy rosman as
he is going to push those two pawns up
the board and they cannot be stopped
nope and now it is a five game lead with
just under six minutes remaining the match
is levies and well we have some fun opening
with the bishops opening and then early d4
just to cause some confusion yeah we needed
maybe more of this in general from him in
this match but it looks like this is going
to be levi's match there's there's pretty
much no mathematical way that canton comes
back because there's just not enough time
on the clock to get those games in right and
we sort of have like an evan's gambit with an
e5 though yeah this this has to be bad queen d5
was coming so that's why he played d5 and queen
a4 i don't know how this works but queen a4 check
at some point it's gonna be painful like queen a4
but you can just go takes on f6 take some
support queen trade take on g7 bishop g5 i'm
sure that's also like pretty reasonable looks
good he plays bishop b3 the calm move which
after 94. he's going to castle just like give
up all his bones yeah we know the vibe here
yeah we know what's happening and look at this
bishop a3 you're typical don't castle can't
get away with that take all my pawns your king
stuck in the center me too i'm here for this yep
19 seconds ticking down here yeah now like knight
d4 f4 f5 type of stuff what we saw at the end of
the alexandra and greg match in this event was
alexander got this amazing checkmate in the final
bullet game it's almost like once you know you've
won the match you kind of let your guard down a
little bit like if you're levy here um maybe he
wouldn't have taken this position if the match was
on the line right you can just play whatever you
want because the match is yours you're moving on
to the next round totally true and queen d3 played
i think levy can please his development knight d7
and yeah absolutely c4 i mean e5 hanging
knight g4 coming bishop back to c7
yep
and yeah there's going to be knight f3 check
like puzzle rush style yeah queen h2 at the
knife through now takes queens i'm sure it
works queen h3 oh this move order hurts too
because there's knight of three check oh knight
f3 queen uh levy oh my goodness he doesn't see it
it would have been beautiful yeah he's still
cruising he's still winning yeah but that
was a nice puzzle rush finish knight f3 check
uncovering mate on h2 isn't that frustrating
in puzzle rush when you find a winning tactic but
it's not the most winning right because there was
checkmate there levy's obviously crushing right
now but he wouldn't have solved it correctly as
he didn't get the check yeah if this was
exactly in a puzzle rush competition that
wouldn't be good enough so what's he up now
uh rook and sorry in exchange in three pawns
three pawns yep bishop v5 probably the most
crucial move in the position looking to trade
okay getting tricky but not tricky enough
just takes takes h6 hoping for not so fast
yeah so it's two and a half minutes left i think
we'll get one more game after this one concludes
and levy just liquidating as he is up three
pawns and then game b3 a4 a3 it's yeah this
will be it and as you mentioned two minutes
left probably one more game for these players
yeah and it's interesting because james is
clearly flustered you saw him just kind of be like
nothing's going right for me in the bullet and the
score has just ballooned thanks to this quickest
time control but if you're james if you're going
to lose the match i think this is absolutely the
way you want to lose the match you don't want to
you know essentially be crushed in the longer time
patrols and then make up some points in the bullet
so he should be proud of himself he should keep
his head hanging high because he played a great
match and i think what he'll regret honestly is
some of these earlier games in the time scrambles
he just wasn't able to work out that especially
the game where levy found that stalemate and
it was a draw of rather than a win for james
yep oh that's a great point and he definitely
should be feeling good about this game levy also
i mean who knows what his game plan coming in was
but i'm sure he knew at the back of his mind that
hey i am a fantastic bullet player and i can win
this match in that time control as long as i stay
steady in the blitz like uh he might not be happy
with how the blitz went for him but at the same
time yeah i'm sure it was a little bit part of
his game plan to to crush the bullet portion yeah
we saw really two different gotham chesses we saw
the early gotham chess who was struggling against
james's tactics and james really played very well
there and then we got like sort of positional
crushing gotham where in those two games in the
three minute portion with the white pieces he just
was kind of in cruise control he just
dominated the board and james had no chance
and then of course he showed his full might here
in the bullet and has taken over this match yep
exactly um here it looks like there's just going
to be a night move into a three piece i'm trying
to see how to get out of that yeah that's wait
so take an e6 some bishop d5 kind of stuff but
oh knight g3 you also hit the rook on f1 the queen
that's why knight f5 was such a good move yeah and
i'm wondering if levy's just looking at the match
clock seeing their 10 seconds left he could just
resign at some point after the 10 seconds yeah he
wants to make sure that time goes to zero no no
sense playing another game honestly for either of
these players as the match is over okay for sure
and well what is black up right now looks like a
lot it's in exchange knight f6 looks like the end
of the game followed by five c4 is resourceful
yeah it feels like lovey's found so many ideas
like that where it looks like the game should just
be over and he plays like c4 just to give himself
chances and that's completely necessary if you're
going to win a match like this okay trae queens
this limit living on the edge there probably
you have to take the queen and go a4 is white
yeah and then what's black up
exactly like an exchange in two pawns
yeah and hey i called it i i mean if he
ends up winning this game i was just saying
that's somehow how these matches tend to end is
the the guy who's gonna end up losing the match
oh that's funny funny that he's still winning
right like 96 checking queen oh you're in the room
that's awesome that's uh that's fun promoting
to a bishop that's a classy way to end that's
the the comedy we expect from from levy there for
sure and for candy ending on a win that at least
feels better than what it previously happened
we are going to grab the players they'll join
us for post-match interviews i'm on we're
going to think of some good questions because
that match had us on the edge of our seats you
you said it best robert um you know full credit
to both levy rosman for obviously the victory
and moving on to the next round but also to james
candy for a incredibly uh good performance and it
made this match a lot closer than i think people
expected it to be and i was thoroughly entertained
so i can't wait to talk to these guys in the post
game interview for sure everybody stay tuned
we'll be right back with both levy rosman and
james kane iii with their thoughts on what
was a fantastic match we'll be right back
and we return with both of our great players
you of course know their faces but let's hear
their thoughts let's start with you levy
congrats on winning was a really fun match
where did you feel like you found your
best form because out of the gates it
seemed a little bit shaky for you and then
suddenly you went on a tear down the stretch
uh bullet kind of saved me uh it was a very
back and forth match i mean i it's it's no i
didn't expect anything less honestly i was doing
some prep this morning and i was like all right
candy and i will fight it out in the blitz and
hopefully i'm within you know i'm up one or two or
and i i didn't even think about the bullet i also
thought the bullet would be close but then as it
got going i was like okay i seem to be making the
better decisions like within one or two seconds so
um stressful as hell though man that was not fun
yeah that was a stressful match for us
watching i mean the the blitz portion was just
topsy-turvy it seemed like the time scrambles
at the end levy you had that one stalemate that
robert and i remember there's like a king on a1
and kante's king was running around and that was
just the wildest game for the emotions of
the chat and us any any thoughts there uh
yeah i was um i i was very happy from the opening
and then as the game was going on i was like what
the hell am i doing i was like like jamming to
my music i was like i'm gonna be up two and then
he just started kicking my ass and i was like
what is going on and then i was gonna resign
i was just gonna resign and i'm like you know
what f and h could be a draw like or whatever a
and z could be a draw and then i was like how do
you draw this with like two seconds on my clock
and that was the end yeah yeah and james on your
end i mean that must have been really deflating
yeah we saw your reaction i mean what was that
experience like how do you calm yourself because
there was so much match left to play well man
that was tough i was like bro what am i doing
you right i'm like but i felt confident and good
because i knew i was like yo only only chant not
chance but the only time that's going to be very
hard for me is going to be in bullet i knew that
ahead of time of course he's 2800 i don't play
like i'm working on really you know i'm really
trying to make gm so i don't play as much bullet
as i used to but at the same time um like i had to
be prepped and i was like man levy's a monster
and bullets so i knew it was going to be uh a
problem there but what how do you bounce back is
hikaru said uh i remember he had an article a long
time ago or maybe he said it but he said um you
gotta have short term memory loss when it comes
to losses or games like that like just you cannot
think about that going into the next game or is
going to affect everything so yeah that's where i
was i was like yep just shake it off keep moving
next game oh i certainly didn't do that there was
that game where i was winning in the end game the
game they went like 40 moves longer than it
had to uh because i i didn't know how much
time i had like for the first time in my life i'm
looking at the board i don't know how much time i
have because i think i have like one second so
i just keep moving i hang a knight and then you
don't take it and then i'm just like i just gotta
move and then finally i look i have three seconds
it's crazy like playing on stream you're just
like talking to chat like drinking thank you
for the prime you got two seconds on the clock and
then like here it's just like like it's insane man
well you know you're mentioning upstream and
of course you both are very popular you had
many fans throughout the match rooting you both
on so let me ask you let's start with you levy
what's the difference for you because you do play
in title tuesdays and things like that but what's
the difference between that and the match you
just played in just this tournament more generally
uh i think i have the same experience today that
i did uh the last time that i that i played this
thing i i honestly like my nerves are like sky
high i might have to take a shot of something
before i play next time it's crazy i haven't
played a meaningful chess game in like two years
three years how long has it been so i like get
amped up for this but when i'm sitting here i'm
like you know you just go you just go i mean you
see it like with the time spent five plus one
i think in five plus one my level of play goes
down thirty three percent at least it's a weird
format i i believe that actually and bullet it
was much stronger i was like where was where did
this come and he was also fast and accurate he was
getting time trouble but i was like man he's going
to be a monster and bullet and that's exactly what
happened i was like man i just want to get a few
games bro like make it close because i knew this
is going to be tough for me i'm not even playing
as much bullet demand 2800 okay that's nasty
and bullets so i was like yeah i know i gotta
this is gonna be tough that one second increment
definitely saved me but it still wasn't enough
time it still wasn't the time bro but it
was uh you know congrats bro it was great
and i felt great about the match but could have
did better bullet yeah the the bullet portion
was entertaining i know robert and i both saw
the pretty much at the beginning of the bullet
portion i think levy was like on camera looking
shocked when you played knight f6 knight back to
and we're all wondering was that was that a
mouse slip like what was that there that was
not a mouse slip big fella that was definitely
something that i play a lot actually because
it just throws people off especially in bullet
knight g8 and we great hit h6 g5 bishop g7 d6 975
c5 go for a queen side attack it's more like a uh
black lions a shout out to simon williams on that
i know a l shot system if you guys are familiar
with that but sort of a combination of both where
you get this swashbuckling ridiculous looking
game especially in bullet chess is something nice
yeah james really caught us off guard with that
one glad to know that was planned and that was fun
and you know people in the chat were mentioning
before and i guess i have to ask both of you i
guess there's breaking news that james harden
was trades the nets levy you're a brooklyn guy
how are you feeling about that uh shocked and
uh wow i'm kind of pissed off actually i don't
want james harden i i didn't want james harden
i don't know oh my god wow you got to lose that
weight that's why that's what i can say you gotta
lose that weight i mean so do i but so does he
robert how do you feel about that better
question oh you know i'm the one who asked
the questions i don't have to answer
them right now yeah you're not happy
i need a rep and you wrap my head around all of it
the last thing that we needed in brooklyn was the
the top three most dramatic players
in the league let's be serious okay
well guys it was an awesome match and really thank
you so much to both you and congrats to you levy
for finally taking it and for james you put up
a great fight you were worthy competitor and
we look forward to more streams of yours in the
near future appreciate it guys thanks guys yeah
congrats levy and as you see the bracket fills
out a little bit more our third match has come
to its conclusion levy rosman the four seed moves
on he awaits the winner of eric rosen and sagar
shah what do you make of that match up in the 512
because if you're a college basketball fan that's
normally where opposites happen yeah you know
fifth seed versus twelve seed i think that
um one of the sort of dark horses or the one of
the people that uh i think the audience might
know the least about in this tournament might be
cigar shaw i mean uh you and i probably uh quite
familiar with him but i i think that people
would be more familiar with eric rosen you
know like very popular on his streams and such
and he's obviously the favorite going in but
i think if this match was any indicator robert
it's like what does a favorite really mean in this
format it's about who shows up on game day because
james canty came in he was only down a single game
and he was leading at many points in this match
it's only done a single game before the bullet so
i think it's gonna be a very exciting match just
like today rosen is the favorite but anything can
happen yeah another matchup of fabulous content
creators cigarshaw also a very strong player and
many people especially on twitch may not be as
familiar but if you're on youtube you should look
up his stuff great content and he may be the most
popular uh person in this match because when he is
streaming when the indian players are playing
oh the audience grows and grows so it will be
interesting to see how he fares over the board and
not in his role's commentator but i'm on you know
it's been fun we will have another match tomorrow
between alessia santoramo and roberto molina
i think we know who the heavy favorite is in that
one roberto is the two seed unless he will have
her hands full but any chance for the 15 seed
i i think i've i've learned my lesson you know
in these matches where for example levy the fourth
seed james canty the third number 13 and how close
was this match to start off there were many points
where kante was leading i've i've learned to you
know not put my money anywhere anywhere near
matches like this because the incredible things
can happen so i'm not counting anyone out and even
in some of the matches like danny versus lawrence
which ended up in a lopsided score it was still
a very entertaining match so it's well worth
your time to tune in certainly and well you know
many more fun chess events coming our way there's
the arena kings as starting starting monday and
the second arena kings will be friday of course
we will have pog champs three everyone should
be really excited about that that is starting
next month the biggest names in the streaming
world v tubers like code miko and of course the
uh celebrities abound including some from
non-streaming platforms like rayne wilson of
the office and daniel negrano the poker legend
amman you know it's been a great time covering
these matches with you i had a blast today and
wow we just were in for a show that was a treat
yeah and the time just like disappeared it always
happens during these matches you never you never
see the time taken away and at the end that was
like a full full cinematic experience i was i
was here for it all commentary with you we had to
chat uh tons of fans and supporters for both sides
we appreciate you know the memes the the spam
you guys enjoying it and uh yeah just a lot of
fun commentating and uh thoroughly entertained for
sure and there is another match tomorrow it starts
three hours earlier so if you're tuning into
this set your clocks because you will not want
to miss that i'm on thank you again thanks to
our producers thanks to everybody who's joined us
throughout all the chats and throughout all
the action we really appreciate you but for now
we're gonna sign off enjoy the rest of your
day and keep having fun with chess take care